Moin, Chatge.
Oh, warum ist die Musik aus? Hä? Die Musik ist gar nicht aus, es war gerade so einfach Songwechsel.
Keck. Wait. Was meine Meinung zu Proxmox war, wir haben sogar zwei Streams dazu gemacht.
Wir haben nicht alles ausprobiert. Ich habe mich ein bisschen
lange dran aufgehängt, das zu clustern.
An sich war es eigentlich relativ einfach.
Leider hat
das Failover
Migrieren der VMs nicht funktioniert.
Und ich bin mir nicht genau sicher, warum.
Das könnte an meinem Setup hier lokal gelegen haben,
weil alle drei Notes selbst virtualisiert waren, weil es am einfachsten war.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es an meinem Setup lag oder an Proxmox.
Ja, aber gut, ich meine,
im Endeffekt
eignet es sich nach wie vor nicht für meine Anwendungszwecke lokal.
Das heißt nichts da so Schlechtes. Ich fand das eigentlich ganz gut.
Also ich denke schon, dass das eine ganz gute Alternative ist, wenn man jetzt nicht super krass Business Enterprise ist gegen VMware oder
Xen, wobei es ist ja nicht mehr Xen. Es ist ja, wie heißt der Kram jetzt, Leute? Es ist ja nicht mehr Xen, sondern es ist
NNNCP
oder sowas. Wie heißt denn der Krempel jetzt? Früher hieß das Xen. Heißt jetzt irgendwie anders.
Also ich kann mir schon vorstellen, dass das für gerade für kleine Reläden, die keinen Bock haben auf Lizenzgebühren
und die vielleicht auch nicht alles das ganze Ökosystem brauchen, was VMware anbietet,
schon glücklich werden können mit Proxmox. Hat keinen schlechten Eindruck gemacht.
Ja, ich glaube, das meine ich. Ja, Hyper-V kann es ja mal komplett klicken. Ich kenne legit niemand. Ernsthaft, niemand, der Hyper-V verwendet.
Außer vielleicht Microsoft in Azure, um Windows zu virtualisieren oder sowas. Keine Ahnung, aber ich kenne niemand. Kennt ihr jemand, der Hyper-V benutzt?
Okay, okay, du hast recht. In dem Sinn, ja,
dann benutzen viele Leute Hyper-V, weil WSL 2 auf Hyper-V passiert. Okay, ja, das ist mein,
ne, aber ich meine es als wirklich als Virtualisierungslösung.
Ihr benutzt nur Hyper-V und was virtualisiert ihr damit? Wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich Windows, oder?
Die leben Hyper-V, MonkaS, Alter. Was ist mit den Leuten verkehrt? Ich verstehe es nicht.
Wenn von Kunde gewünscht, dann muss man einfach mal sagen, Kunde, du weißt nicht, was du willst. Geh mir nicht auf den Sack. Such dir jemand anderes.
Du musst dann einfach sagen
und danach
und dann einfach sagen, sucht euch jemand anderes.
Ja, ja, in dem Sinne hast du schon recht, oder habt ihr schon recht, verwenden wahrscheinlich viel mehr Hyper-V, als man denkt, aber ich meine jetzt halt als
Server-Virtualisierungslösung, ja.
Anstelle von, vor allem ja zum Beispiel, da kenne ich echt niemand, der das benutzt.
Ja, Proxmox hat auch keinen schlechten Eindruck gemacht.
Aber ich kenne mich eh nicht so super aus im Internet.
Also ich habe mehr als den ESX mal installiert, habe ich nicht gemacht, mit 4MW.
Ich glaube, das haben wir sogar auf dem,
sogar im Stream gemacht.
Oh, ich bin halt übelst müde, ey.
Haben wir sogar im Stream gemacht, ESX installiert, als es mal so eine Beta-Version von Raspberry Pi gab, war eigentlich ganz witzig.
Weiß ich gar nicht, ob das überhaupt noch offiziell,
ob es das überhaupt noch offiziell gibt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das überhaupt noch offiziell gibt.
Ob es das überhaupt noch offiziell gibt.
Ich kann immer schreiben, ESX
ARM Edition, ja tatsächlich, guck mal.
Das, das wird permanent noch, noch geupdatet, ja anscheinend.
Gibt's noch. Interessant. Ich hätte gedacht, das war so ein Einmalversuch.
Ne, aber ich habe es gekauft mittlerweile.
Ich hätte echt Bock drauf. Also ja, Moment, stimmt nicht. Natürlich habe ich es mir angeschaut. Ich habe mir sehr viele, viele,
ich will nicht sagen alle, aber viele der Playtests habe ich gespielt.
Und die Early Access Version hatte ich mir auch gekauft vor ein paar Tagen, aber ich habe es noch nicht gespielt. Das heißt, ich weiß nicht,
ob im Vergleich zu dem,
also jetzt im Early Access, ob im Vergleich zu den Playtests irgendwas Nennenswertes hinzugekommen ist.
Außer, dass die Playtests, also ich muss sagen, ich habe nichts gegen minimalistische Grafikstils,
aber der war mir doch etwas zu,
zu zweidimensional.
Ja, ich weiß, dass es ein 3D-Game ist, aber der, du hast, du hast nicht richtigen Schatten gehabt und die Maps waren extrem detailarm.
Also, grafisch hat es mir nicht gefallen. Auch wenn ich nichts gegen minimalistische Grafikstile und Pixel-Grafikstile schon gar nicht habe.
Max Neuss von der Bewerbungsfront. Moment, sag mal, Nick Silver,
du warst das mit dem, mit denen, die dich mit falschem Namen anschreiben und sowas, gell?
Die irgendwie total lost sind mit der Bewerbung.
Okay, also, was gibt es Neues? Lul. Lul ist generell bei Bewerbungen immer das Beste, was passieren kann.
Erstmal Lul.
Und es könnte nur noch getoppt werden, vielleicht von LulW.
Okay, Lul.
Welche Maus ich zum Spielen benutze? Eine Logitech Pro Wireless.
Davor hatte ich eine ähnliche, aber mit
Kabel, aber ich habe jetzt schon seit letzten drei Jahren oder so.
Wireless Maus und so ein Wireless Charging Ding.
Okay.
Vorhin Anno von einer Bewerbung bekommen. Wir würden sie total gerne kennenlernen, aber mit ihren Gehaltsvorstellungen können wir nicht verwirklichen,
weil wir sonst das Gehaltsgefüge in der Abteilung... Ja, Pech gehabt. Es ist wirklich so...
Es ist doch ganz einfach, die sollen einfach alle anderen, die ähnliche Aufgaben übernehmen, auch mehr bezahlen. Und fertig.
Wir würden sie mit X, Y und Z einschrauben. Das wäre weniger als das, was ich jetzt für die...
Ja, ich meine, hey, ehrlich, man kann es ihnen doch gar nicht übel nehmen, dass sie es mal probieren. Es ist zwar ziemlich
unwahrscheinlich, aber in der heutigen Zeit, ich würde es ihnen nicht übel nehmen, dass sie es einfach mal probieren.
Die finden halt keine Leute und die werden wahrscheinlich dafür auch keine gescheiten Leute finden, aber
probieren kann man es.
Bei der Gelegenheit fällt mir immer wieder die Story ein vom Kollege, der sich auch wo beworben hat. Habe ich euch ja schon erzählt.
Der hat sich beworben und die haben geschrieben
Gehaltsspanne, also das haben die offensiv in die Werbung geschrieben, also in die in die Stellenanzeige geschrieben. Gehaltsspanne 95 bis 105 K.
Und da hat er mit denen ein Interview geführt. Erst mit irgendeinem Typ in England, weil, was für ihn kein Problem ist, weil er ist ja
Native Speaker
und dann noch mit, dann haben sie noch eine Bewerbung in Deutschland mit ihm gemacht und dann hatten sie sogar noch so einen
so einen, wie nennt man das, wo man die Leute fragt, so
lasst uns mal durchspielen, wie würden sie einen Supportfall bearbeiten und sowas.
Also er hatte drei Bewerbungsrunden mit denen und die waren sich dann eigentlich immer einig und er war auch immer, sie haben immer gesagt, super Kandidat, ja, das
lief wunderbar und am Ende wollen sie, wollten sie ihn einstellen
und dann haben die gesagt, jetzt ernsthaft müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, er hat drei
drei Bewerbungsgespräche mit denen geführt. Drei Stück und sie waren sich immer einig, auch übers Geld waren sie sich schon einig
und am Ende haben sie zu ihm gesagt, ja, wir würden sie einstellen
für 75 K.
Und da hat er gesagt, hä?
Es ging doch immer um 95 bis 105 K. Gehaltsspanne, das haben wir doch jedes Mal geklärt, warum kommt ihr mir jetzt mit 75 K.
Und da haben die als Begründung gesagt, ja, also
das, wir haben eine Seniorstelle ausgeschrieben, aber in unserer Budgetplanung war kein Platz mehr für eine Seniorstelle.
Und da hat er sich auch nur noch gedacht,
Kack, leave. Und hat halt gesagt, nö, dann nicht.
Aber da musste man überlegen, da fragt man sich allen Ernstes, also was denken die sich dabei?
Denken die ernsthaft, irgendjemand lässt sich schon
absichtlich verarschen?
Bevor er unterschreibt, also
danach wirst du ja oft genug noch verarscht, aber davor?
Und
Und was, was erwarten die sich dabei? So nach dem Motto, oh ja,
ihr habt mich jetzt so sehr überzeugt, dass ich auch für 20 bis 30 K. weniger bei euch arbeite.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was mit denen los ist, ja.
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Man weiß es nicht.
Was ist denn das?
Kenne ich nicht. Oder vielleicht doch, aber ich kann es gerade nicht zuordnen.
Also wenn die, also ganz ehrlich, wenn die schon so anfangen,
ich meine, hey,
da würde ich mich darauf einlassen,
wenn es vertraglich, genau wie du das sagst, wenn es vertraglich garantiert ist, dass ich danach
deutlich mehr bekomme.
Also insofern, aber eigentlich sind solche Vorschläge schon immer
sehr zweifelhaft und
ich würde nicht von ausgehen, dass die
in Zukunft mir entgegenkommen.
Ja,
ja, ist echt so.
Du brauchst noch ein Bewerbungsschreiben für mein 9. Klasse-Praktikum?
Alter, bist du in der, du bist in der 9. Klasse erst? Leute, summa detected.
Nicht schlecht. Ich dachte, ich habe nur alte Säcke hier.
Braucht man eigentlich für ein Praktikum, wenn man im Lebenslauf bleibt? Ich würde immer ein Foto reinmachen in den Lebenslauf, ja.
Sogar ich habe mich geleakt
im Lebenslauf.
Klar, brauchst du ein Foto.
Ich würde immer ein Foto im Lebenslauf reinmachen.
Klar, macht ein Foto im Lebenslauf. Das ist viel netter, persönlicher und
sieht einfach besser aus. Ich würde ein Foto im Lebenslauf reinmachen.
Mach ein ordentliches Bild. Du musst nicht zum Fotograf gehen. Lass dich mit dem Handy fotografieren und mach irgendwie einen halbwegs normalen Eindruck, wenn es gut ist.
Auch geil.
So nach dem Motto, ja, wir geben ihnen mehr Geld, indem wir ihnen weniger Geld geben. Five-Hat-Time, stimmen sie zu? Ja, nein.
PotatoBob schreibt, ich hatte am Montag einen Bewerber, der seine Aufgabe für das Assessment Center angesehen hat, gesagt, nee, darauf habe ich keinen Bock wieder gegangen.
Hey, ich meine, wenigstens ist er ehrlich. Ich würde gerne ein Foto in den Lebenslauf reinmachen, aber ich habe keine Lust, das zu machen.
Ehrlich, da wisst ihr, was Sache ist, ja? Was habt ihr denn gefragt? Worauf hat er denn keinen Bock gehabt?
Also, wenn ihr mich fragen würdet, wie würden sie einen
First-Level-Support-Fall angehen, so nach dem Motto, ein Endanwender ruft sie an und hat Probleme beim Öffnen der Anwendung, dann würde ich auch sagen,
keinen Bock drauf, ich gehe wieder.
Aber es kommt natürlich darauf an, was es für ein Job ist, ob man es von vornherein weiß, dass sowas auf einen zukommt.
Und sagt doch mal, was ihr gefragt habt. Ich meine, du musst dich den genauen Wortlaut schreiben.
Wie macht man einen MySQL-Surfer, der nicht Local Host ist und man trotzdem in die Tabellen schauen kann?
Hä?
Ah, jetzt verstehe ich, was du meinst.
Also, ich meine, auf irgendeinem Surfer muss der MySQL-Dienst ja letztendlich laufen. Du musst einstellen, dass der nicht nur Listened...
Also, du musst irgendwo einstellen. Ich habe keine Ahnung von MySQL.
Du kannst sicherlich einstellen, dass der nicht nur Local Listened, sondern auch auf...
Also, dass er nicht nur auf Local Host Listened, sondern auch auf dem externen Interface.
Dann kannst du auch von außen drauf zugreifen, also von außen, vom angrenzenden Netzwerk.
Aber bei der Gelegenheit würde ich dem Ding dann auch ein Passwort geben, sonst ist es ein bisschen doof.
Das ist aber eigentlich der Normalfall. Ich weiß gar nicht, Listened MySQL default-mäßig nur auf Local Host?
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht.
Oh ja, das ist auch komplett überzeugend immer, ja.
Ja.
Würdet ihr nicht auch gerne der Firma helfen und dafür auf Gehaltsverzichten?
Ich meine, ich will jetzt nicht sagen, würde ich nie im Leben machen.
Unter den richtigen Umständen, in der richtigen Firma, mit dem richtigen...
Eventuell, ja.
Sagen wir mal...
Ich würde jetzt zu irgendeinem Start-Up wechseln,
und dann würde ich das dann auch machen.
Und dann würde ich das dann auch machen.
Ich würde jetzt zu irgendeinem Start-Up wechseln
und da weniger Geld kriegen,
aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen fände ich es mega geil
und wäre da voll dabei
und hätte vielleicht auch irgendwie Anteile bekommen.
Und vielleicht,
vielleicht würde ich das dann machen.
Aber so unter jetzigen Umständen
sehe ich es nicht ein,
warum ich auf Gehalt verzichten soll
und quasi
mich gleich anstrengen soll.
Das ist irgendwie...
Wir haben das ausgemacht.
Das steht im Vertrag drin.
Ich halte mich dran.
Die anderen sollten sich auch dran halten.
Nee, sagt mir gar nichts.
Wenn du mir eine gute schickst, gucke ich mir die an.
Leute, ich habe nichts für heute geplant.
Ich bin übelst im Arsch.
Ich muss mal wieder nach Frankfurt fahren.
Die Klimaanlage ging natürlich in der Bahn nicht.
Die Bahn hatte 20 Minuten Verspätung.
Ey, das ist so ein Kackglatt.
Achso, die Uhrzeit im Zug hat übrigens auch nicht gestimmt.
Müsst ihr euch das mal überlegen.
Bei der Anzeige im Zug heute
hat wirklich gar nichts gestimmt.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Es stimmt weder
der Tag, noch der Monat,
noch das Jahr,
noch
die Uhrzeit.
Nicht mal die Minuten
und die...
Nicht eine Zahl da drauf stimmt
auf dem ganzen Ding hier.
Und ob das WC blockiert ist,
wäre ich auch unschlüssig.
Doch, die 2 am Anfang stimmt noch.
Ja, ja, ja, ihr habt recht.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, dass ja 1000 stimmt.
Ja, vielleicht war die
BIOS-Batterie leer, wie jemand geschrieben hat
auf Twitter.
Also, wenn du eine Stellanzeige hast,
schick her, dann gucken wir uns die an.
Wie gesagt, ich bin übelst im Arsch.
Ich habe heute nichts geplant.
Ich habe mir gedacht, ey, ich habe jetzt die Auswahl.
Ich gammele jetzt 2 Stunden hier noch vom Rechner rum
oder ich mache Stream an.
Also kann ich auch einfach 2 Stunden im Stream rumgammeln,
wenn gut ist.
Schwätzen über irgendwas.
Und 22 Uhr, wisst ihr, was ist, ne?
Wettgetime.
Weißt du eigentlich,
warum ich früher beim Dual-Booten von
Windows und Linux die Zeit immer Brocken war?
Das ist
eine gute Frage. Weiß ich nicht.
Aber ich weiß,
dass es früher Probleme gab.
Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das weiß ich, da gab es...
Ich weiß nicht, woran es lag.
Abschließend. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob es das Problem nicht
heute immer noch gibt.
Vielleicht hat es irgendwas mit der BIOS-Zeit
zu tun oder so. Keine Ahnung.
Nee, weiß ich nicht.
Weil sich Linux und Windows nicht einig sind,
ob man die Real-Time-Clock
in lokaler Zeit
oder UTC speichert.
Das kann natürlich sein.
Wenn Linux die Zeit auf UTC plus Zeitzone
setzt, die in der Config steht,
und Windows speichert das quasi immer
in lokaler Zeit. Das könnte natürlich sein.
Alternativ kann man das aber wahrscheinlich
relativ easy fixen.
Indem man bei beiden Systemen beim Start
einfach einmal NTP querieren lässt.
Leute, ich werde bald 39.
Ich weiß, ich sage das hier im Stream.
Aber ich habe letztens
das übelst deprimierende Video geguckt
auf YouTube.
Wurde mir empfohlen. Wahrscheinlich wissen die,
dass ich langsam in dem Alter bin.
Und die haben gesagt, dass Leute zwischen
zwischen
Lass mal überlegen.
Ich glaube zwischen 35 und 40
oder so.
Haben die gesagt. So in dieser Zeit.
Zwischen 35 und 40.
Dass da total viele
Leute bescheuerte
Dinge machen.
Ja, so wie zum Beispiel
seit 10 Jahren verheiratet und an fremd gehen.
Gut, das Problem habe ich nicht.
Ich müsste erst mal 10 Jahre verheiratet sein.
Aber so ganz komische Dinge machen.
Weil sie mit 35 bis 40
zum ersten Mal
realisieren, dass das Leben
auch mal vorbeigeht.
Und da kann ich mich tatsächlich mit identifizieren.
Wissen tut das jeder.
So wirklich realisieren, dass das auch
echt der Fall ist.
Das macht man echt erst ein bisschen später.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich sagen würde,
dass mich das super belastet oder so.
Aber ja, das stimmt schon.
Früher denkt man sich immer noch so.
Gut, ich bin jetzt 15.
So gefühlt
8 mal 15 werden.
7 mal 15 werden.
Das würde gar kein Problem.
Man merkt das.
Man weiß es immer schon.
Aber so wirklich realisieren,
dass du nicht.
Früher war das im Kopf immer so.
Ich habe mir früher immer gedacht nach dem Motto
Ey, wenn du das nicht machst,
ist eigentlich kein Problem.
Du kannst es immer noch machen.
Nach dem Motto, ach, jetzt machst du das
anstelle von dem.
Und guck dir das an.
Und in 5 Jahren kannst du
was anderes machen, wenn du da keinen Bock mehr drauf hast.
Und da realisiert man halt
irgendwann mal, okay, prinzipiell
kann man immer noch was Neues machen.
Aber du bist halt nicht
irgendwie beliebig oft
20 oder so, um dann Sachen
dort zu machen. Du kannst nicht sagen, ah, ich bin jetzt 20.
Ich würde jetzt gerne das machen.
Aber ich mache lieber das.
Und in 5 Jahren einfach das gleiche nochmal machen.
Und dann entscheide ich mich anders.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Das denkt man sich so im Hinterkopf früher.
Aber irgendwann stellt man dann schon
fest so, naja, ganz so
ist es auch nicht.
Aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass mir das wahnsinnig zusetzt.
Ich sage, oh nein.
Bald dead girl.
Dass die Zeit so schnell rumgeht,
liegt ja glaube ich an 2 Dingern.
Das erste ist, aber das ist
bei weitem nicht so extrem,
ist, dass dein Gehirn
langsamer wird
und dir deswegen das alles schneller vorkommt.
Aber
das ist mit 30 wahrscheinlich
nicht das Problem. Das Problem mit 30
ist wahrscheinlich eher
so die ganze Kombination aus allem.
Wenn du viele Sachen machst, die einfach
bekannt sind,
dann hast du nicht,
du musst ja deine Zeit irgendwie einteilen.
Und das machst du ja oftmals an irgendwelchen coolen Erlebnissen
und Sachen fest. So nach dem Motto,
in 2 Tagen habe ich das Geile gemacht.
Oh, vor einem halben Jahr war doch noch das.
Und wenn du halt so einen geregelten
Tagesablauf hast,
da ist jetzt halt nicht unbedingt
alle paar Tage so ein super Highlight, wo du sagst,
oh ja, da kann ich mich, und oh, dann war das.
Du denkst dir so,
hm, was war das letzte geile,
also geil in Form von
toll, oder kann ja
auch das letzte geile
gewesen sein. Und dann denkst du dir,
ah ok, das war dann und dann,
ein halbes Jahr her.
Das fällt einem dann schon ein,
aber da liegt
das wahrscheinlich
ähnlich dran.
Also wahrscheinlich liegt das eher da dran.
Leute,
also, wenn man eins
bei aktuellen Diskussionen
im Internet sieht,
ist,
dass es ziemlich egal ist,
was irgendwie rein
rechtlich oder offiziell der Fall ist.
Die Leute rasten aus
bei Dingen, die komplett unklar,
unentschieden oder sonst was sind.
Und das hat natürlich einen Grund,
ich will mich jetzt nicht
über Social Media auslassen, aber einer der Gründe ist,
dass Leute
halt auch gewisse
Sachen bevorzugen,
ob das nun im Gesetz
steht oder nicht.
Wenn im Gesetz steht,
wir suchen jemanden,
da und dafür, und es bewerben sich Leute,
und
du hast Bewerber,
die ganz gut passen mit einem Foto,
und du guckst dir den Typ an und denkst dir,
ey, der sieht mir schon sympathisch aus,
versus einen Typ ohne Foto,
versus einen Typ, der dir absolut unsympathisch
aussieht auf der Bewerbung,
dann ist klar, du willst wahrscheinlich
erstmal den einladen, der dir ein sympathisches Bild
auf der Bewerbung drauf hat.
Du wirst nämlich sagen,
den anderen, ah, ich lehne sie jetzt ab,
weil sie kein Foto haben, oder sie sind hässlich,
das will sie nicht, das wäre ja auch,
wenn sie mich bescheuert, das würde ich,
würde ich ja auch als Arbeitgeber
nicht sagen, ich würde halt einfach
ganz normal förmlich absagen.
Aber die Leute haben nun mal sowas,
deswegen, ich denke, zu einer Bewerbung
gehört tatsächlich ein Foto dabei.
Das braucht kein super Business-Foto
zu sein, und es muss auch nicht irgendwie
vom Fotograf
im Anzug sein, oder sonst was,
aber man sollte nicht total
schäbig aussehen, und es sollte halbwegs
gescheit fotografiert sein.
Also jetzt vielleicht nicht von der Webcam schräg
von unten, dass man halb in die Nase
reingucken kann, oder so, ja.
So irgendwie ein halbwegs
sympathisches, normales Bild,
wo man nicht total
schlampig und schäbig ausschaut.
Also ich würde euch ja mein
Bewerbungsfoto zeigen, das sah auch mega beschissen aus.
Aber ich kann euch mein Bewerbungsfoto nicht zeigen,
da würde ich wieder liegen.
Also mein Bewerbungsfoto sah mega beschissen aus,
weil, erstens war ich da noch
20 Kilo schwerer,
zweitens wurde das unter ultraschlechten
Belichtungsdingern, also
total überbelichtet aufgenommen,
und das habe ich von der alten Arbeit,
da haben die mal Fotos gemacht
für die Zutrittskarte,
dementsprechend schlecht war das auch,
und das noch raufskaliert in Word.
Mini-Foto für die Zutrittskarte raufskaliert.
Und warum? Weil ich zu faul war.
Ist Neowim echt so
Pork wie manche YouTuber propagieren?
Ja, ist es. Allerdings
propagieren das manche YouTuber
tatsächlich, finde ich, ein bisschen zu sehr als
Allzweckwaffe. Ich weiß, das ist Geschmackssache
und viele sehen das so,
aber ich bin der Meinung,
Neowim muss, oder generell Wim,
also die Stärken von Wim
sind das schnelle Editieren von lokalen Files
oder über SSH, dort auf dem
Server lokale Files,
und weniger das Aufbohren
zu
super featurereichen IDEs.
Das geht, dank Language Server
heute sogar relativ gut,
dank Autocomplete Plugins
und allen möglichen
Code Explorer und sonst was, kannst du
das sicherlich cool machen, aber ich
denke trotzdem, wenn es
rein um die Hilfen
und den Komfort geht, beispielsweise in der Sprache
wie C Sharp für .NET
zu entwickeln, dann kann man das
in Wim machen, man konnte das auch vor Jahren schon
in Emacs machen, wenn man
aufgebaut hat zu einer IDE, aber
ich behaupte mal, dass man immer noch besser fährt,
wenn man beispielsweise Rider benutzt für .NET
oder meinetwegen auch
Visual Studio, aber nicht Visual Studio Code
in dem Fall,
als das, aber ja,
Neowim ist ziemlich pock
und dank den ganzen
Plugin-Möglichkeiten und dem Lua-Support
kann man dort auch sehr
viele geile Sachen mittlerweile machen, also es ist
wahrscheinlich mit eines der besten
Editors,
wenn es um Erweiterbarkeit
und Customizability geht,
neben Visual Studio Code
natürlich, ja, Visual Studio Code
ist ja auch dank Javascript
und dank Javascript-Plugins
customizable und
extendbar
ohne Ende.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich Arch wieder installiere,
warum machst du nicht mein Setup?
Warum, Chat?
Warum habe ich euch zweimal auf?
Was ist da los?
Okay, ich mache euch hier wieder zu,
weil hier wollte ich eigentlich
meine VM aufmachen.
Ja, warum machst du nicht mein Setup?
Windows
und Linux in der VM?
Ich meine,
du kannst manche Sachen nicht unter Linux
machen in der VM, aber das sind,
oder nicht gut machen, aber das sind eh Sachen,
die Linux nicht unbedingt
als Stärken aufzuweisen hat.
Ja doch, er will ja anscheinend Windows,
weil er Sachen hat, die
unter Windows besser funktionieren.
Ich mache das auch so, ich streame unter Windows,
ich spiele unter Windows, ich mache mein Video-Kram,
Thumbnail-Kram, Bildbearbeitungs-Kram unter Windows
und alles andere, wo Linux
gut ist, benutze ich Linux.
Erster Desktop Windows,
zweiter Desktop Linux und
ist auch performantechnisch kein Problem
und natürlich ist es Arch Linux
by the way, logisch, ja.
Beispielbewerbungsfoto,
exakt so sollte das aussehen, ja.
Also ernsthaft, Leute,
wenn ich eine Bewerbung bekommen würde,
mit
dem als Bild
und guten Qualifikationen,
den Kerl würde ich sogar einladen.
Achso, quasi, er sollte gar nichts so direkt
programmieren, sondern eher so Architektur
erklären.
Ja, da würde man eigentlich schon als Senior Entwickler
erwarten, dass der da ein bisschen was
zustande bekommt.
Da könnte ja sogar ich was zu sagen und ich bin
kein Senior Entwickler.
Ich bin Senior Five
Twitch-Chatter.
Wahrscheinlich hätten die das
auch noch gemacht.
Ja, war heute schon anstrengend.
Aber was mich angestrengt hat, ist halt das
Hin- und Zurückfahren nach Frankfurt zusätzlich noch und die Bahn,
die mich wieder übelst abgefuckt hat.
Okay, Stellanzeige.
Okay, gucken
wir mal rein. Mail Buddy in
Hamburg.
Silver, ist das was von euch oder ist
das einfach nur random was?
Wo ich mir angucken
soll
im Stream. Okay, wir machen erst mal
Darkseam an.
Also, was haben wir denn hier?
Bin ich mal gespannt.
Also ich kann dir sagen, ob ich mich
da drauf bewerben würde oder nicht.
Nee, das ist ja nur Windows-Zeug, oder?
Okay, also.
Mir juckt die Nase.
Die Grundlage jeder IT ist eine sichere
und skalierbare IT-Infrastruktur.
Leute, wie wird hier skaliert?
Wie skalieren wir?
Wir skalieren nur
orthogonal, nee,
diagonal, korrekt.
Wir skalieren nämlich horizontal und
vertikal gleichzeitig.
Magst du Proxmox?
Ich fand's echt nicht übel, ganz ehrlich.
Ich fand's nicht schlecht. Auch das
High-Availability-Setup
wirkte relativ easy, auch wenn's am Ende nicht
funktionierte, aber das lag wahrscheinlich an mir oder an
meinem Setup. Für meinen Anwendungszweck
lokal bei mir daheim ist es aber trotzdem nix.
Okay, also.
Die Grundlage jeder IT ist eine sichere
und skalierbare IT-Infrastruktur.
Dem würde ich prinzipiell mal
so als pauschal
hingeschmissen, würde ich sagen. Ja, ist okay, würde ich auch so
sehen. Eine gut konzipierte
IT-Infrastruktur ist nicht nur für die effiziente
Arbeit der Mitarbeiter wichtig,
sondern auch für die Sicherheit und Verfügbarkeit
der Unternehmenssteuern. Oh ja, okay.
Aufgaben. Aber was ist es überhaupt für eine Stelle?
Ein IT-Administrator,
Systemadministrator,
männlich-weiß-deutsch, in Hamburg.
Als IT-Administrator
bist du für die Konzeptionierung und
Implementierung von cloud-basieren Infrastrukturen
Office 365
und Azure, okay,
zuständig. Allein schon das
in einem Atemzug zu nennen, ist doch
total hängen geblieben. Das eine
ist quasi so eine, ja wie soll man sagen,
Office-as-a-Service-Geschichte und das andere
ist eine komplette Cloud.
Wie nennt man sowas wie Azure
eigentlich? Ich hätte jetzt gesagt,
komplette Cloud, kompletter
Cloud-Anbieter, aber
Cloud-Provider?
Infrastructure-as-a-Service, ja ist es ja nicht
nur. Cloud-Provider
kann man es, glaube ich, nennen. Cloud-Plattform!
Das ist das, was ich suche.
Genau, Cloud-Plattform.
Das ist ja eine komplette Cloud-Plattform, wo du
alles mögliche machen kannst. Von
Datenbanken, Manage Datenbanken, Manage Kubernetes
oder
Manage NoSQL,
Public PubSub,
DNS, VMs,
Functions,
alles.
Deine Aufgabe umfasst die
Administration und strategische Weiterentwicklung
der Office 365 Services.
Da hätte ich schon mal keinen Bock drauf.
Umsetzung und Mitgestaltung
von Office 365
Projekten. Oh, da hätte ich auch schon mal
absolut keinen Bock drauf.
Das sieht mir sehr nach
Kack Windows aus.
First Level Support!
First Level Supporter, Mitarbeiter
bei Fragen rund um Office 365
sowie die Betreuung und
Schulung. Übrigens,
wisst ihr, was wir denen mal schreiben sollten?
Dass das eigentlich gar nicht mehr Office 365
heißt.
Das heißt mittlerweile offiziell
Microsoft 365.
Falls ihr das nicht wusstet.
Niemand benutzt diese
neue Bezeichnung, aber offiziell heißt das so.
Guck, das heißt Microsoft 365.
Ja.
Office.com
ist Microsoft 365.
Okay, First Level Support.
Boah, nee, ernsthaft.
Sowie die Betreuung und Schulung
der Mitarbeiter im Bereich.
Boah, Alter, hätte ich da keinen Bock drauf.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen,
Office Skills ist nicht unbedingt
jemand, den ich administrieren
lassen würde und umgedreht. Das eine hat doch mit dem
anderen gar nichts zu tun.
Das ist komplett bescheuert,
ehrlich gesagt, sowas in einem.
Wirklich, Real Talk, es ist
komplett absurd, das in einer Person
zu machen. Jemand, der richtig gut
sich mit Office auskennt und da Mitarbeiter
schulen kann, ist nicht zwangsläufig jemand,
den ich an meine Infrastruktur dranlassen würde zum
administrieren und umgedreht.
Das ergibt
überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Hin und wieder vor Ort Einsätze beim Kunden.
Oh, es wird ja immer...
Ist das eine Top-Liste
nach unten, was ich immer weniger machen
will? Ist aber Standard bei
kleineren Teams. Es ist bescheuert.
Also, wenn ich zum Beispiel Ahnung habe
von
4MWare und ich mache
intern so ein paar Workshops zu 4MWare,
vollkommen okay, da bin ich ja auch in meinem Gebiet.
Aber ich bin Administrator für die
Infrastruktur, unter anderem für
die Infrastruktur hinter Office 365.
Das heißt doch nicht, dass ich Office Checker bin
und den Leuten erklären können, wie sie ein Textkursiv
machen. Nein, es geht
um die Betreuung und Schulung
der Mitarbeiter im Bereich 300...
Das heißt, ich soll denen erklären, wie ich mein Kramkursiv
mache. Und wenn die das nicht meinen,
dann haben sie es beschissen geschrieben.
Aber ich finde das komplett absurd, das in einer Person zu machen.
Okay.
Dokumentation bei der generellen...
Ja, okay.
Dokumentation bei der
generellen Administration unserer
IT-Landschaft.
Das ist auch so,
schreib mir einen Satz, der so vage wie möglich
klingt und dann hauen wir den in die Stellenanzeige.
Du kommst aus Hamburg
oder Umgebung. Ah, das heißt kein Remote,
nur vor Ort. Abgeschlossene technische
Berufsausbildung mit... Okay.
Quereinstieg. Okay, alles klar.
Hohes Interesse an neuen Technologien
cloudlos im Office 365. Ach, hier
ist es, Microsoft 365. Die wissen doch,
dass es Microsoft 365 heißt.
Haben das drei
verschiedene Personen geschrieben, die Stellenanzeige
oder wie? Erste Erfahrung
mit Chitrix,
VM und VMware. Ja, okay.
Sehr gut Deutsch
und Englischkenntnisse in Wort und Schrift.
Benefits. Okay,
jetzt kommt's. Viel
Eigenverantwortung von Tag 1.
Ich weiß jetzt
nicht, ob das so ein krasser Benefit
ist, einfach reingeschmissen
zu werden und
hey, cool, du bist ja der neue Admin.
Ja, dann mach mal.
So liest sich das nämlich.
Das klingt jetzt nicht so sehr nach
krassem Benefit.
Ein Spänefit, oder?
Ey, guck mal, der Admin, der neue.
Auf geht's, Jungs, gib ihm.
Auf, auf.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man
den Text kursiv macht. Zeig mal gleich,
wie ich meinen Text kursiv mache. Und fett.
Fett und kursiver
Text. In Ordnung, danke
für den Sub.
Ein attraktives Startup.
Was? Das ist ein Startup?
MailBuddy GmbH, das ist ein Startup.
Die Stellenanzeige
ist eigentlich null nach Startup.
Also,
nicht, dass ich Experte bin,
in Startup-Stellenanzeigen,
aber ich muss sagen, die besseren
oder sag mal, zumindest die
die irgendwie, wie soll ich sagen,
innovativeren Stellenanzeigen
habe ich bisher tatsächlich eher bei Startups gesehen.
Zum Beispiel könnt ihr euch noch an diese
PAP-Piraten
Piraten-PAP-Piraten-Crew
oder wie die hießen, erinnern?
Da hätte ich zwar
keinen Bock hinzugehen, aber die waren schon
ganz okay von der Stellenanzeige her.
Oder was
ich mega cringe fand, war auch diese
Du bist ein
JavaScript-Wizard und sowas.
Aber das ist
ja, das ist echt
naja, also
Okay, die sagen nicht, dass sie
ein Startup sind, die sagen, sie haben eine attraktive
Startup-Atmosphäre
in einem hochmotivierten Team mit flachen
Hierarchien. Okay, das
sagt ja fast jeder. Also nicht Startup-Atmosphäre,
sondern hochmotiviertes Team mit flachen Hierarchien
und kurzen Entscheidungswegen.
Ich bilde mir sogar ein,
dass irgendwie sowas in der Richtung
in der Stellenanzeige stand,
wo ich mich jetzt, also
für meinen aktuellen Job
und wenn wir eins
nicht sind
oder nicht haben,
dann sind es super flache Hierarchien
und kurze Entscheidungswege.
Bei uns ist es sogar so,
wenn du eine Software auf deinem Windows-Notebook
haben willst, dann musst du erstmal einen Workflow anstoßen,
der vorneweg drei Monate braucht.
Wir sind das Gegenteil von kurzen Entscheidungswegen.
Gut,
bei denen kann das aber durchaus so sein.
Gestaltungsräume im Rahmen
ihrer Tätigkeiten sowie ein Team
Okay, ja
Office im Zentrum
Hamburgs direkt
am Neuen Wall.
Alles klar, keine Ahnung, wo das ist.
Ich kenne von Hamburg nur den Hauptbahnhof
und
die umliegende
tja
Straßen
dort
kommt man dann auf irgendeinen Fluss oder so
ich weiß nicht, was das für ein Fluss ist
und wisst ihr, woher ich das kenne?
Ich hab da mal zu meiner Zeit,
wo ich 24-7 MMO-Kreiselgrind
gemacht hab, mal
einen Grill besucht,
dass ich über MMOs kennengelernt hab.
Das war im Nachhinein
keine allzu gute Idee,
aber
nachher ist man immer schlauer.
Coole, regelmäßige Team-Events.
Leute, also wenn das
hier oben ja noch nicht abschreckend genug gewesen wäre,
spätestens jetzt ist es
vorbei. Guck mal, und sogar den Obstkorb
gibt's dabei.
Die haben ja alles dabei.
Okay,
also,
ich will die jetzt nicht zu sehr flamen,
denn, ehrlich
gesagt, es kann
durchaus sein,
dass das gar kein schlechter
Arbeitgeber ist.
Die Stellenanzeige ist aber schlecht.
Und die Stellenanzeige ist halt das,
was man im Endeffekt auch
als ersten Eindruck hat, und das,
was wir jetzt hier im Endeffekt halt auch bewerten können.
Der Arbeitgeber muss nicht schlecht
sein, aber die Stellenanzeige ist schlecht.
Okay, was sagen die denn über
sich selbst? Wir gucken
mal kurz auf die Webseite von denen.
Einfach mal, just for fun.
MailBuddy, okay,
krasse Bewertung, aber die
haben sich alles, das sind einfach Mitarbeiterbewertungen
wahrscheinlich. MailBuddy bietet
IT-Service und IT-Sicherheit für KMUs.
KMUs sind, wenn ich richtig liege,
kleine und mittelständische Unternehmen.
Oder ist KMU auch noch irgendwas anderes?
Okay, moderne
Webseite finde ich schon mal nicht
schlecht, wenn auch
mir zu viel moderne Webseite, aber
wenigstens mal einer,
die eine gescheite Webseite haben.
Das geht schon mal.
Die geht schon mal klar.
Ich bin kein Fan der Ein-Fade-Dinger
und so, aber gescheite
Typografie, heißt das auf Deutsch?
Typografie?
Und
auch, okay, der Kontrast hier ist jetzt
nicht so geil, muss man sagen, aber ansonsten
geht in Ordnung, wenigstens mal eine gescheite Webseite.
Was ist
CISO? Oder CISO as a Service?
Okay, das ist zu viel Wall of Text.
CISO?
CISO
as a Service?
Bei dem Unternehmen die Dienste unserer
Chief Information Security
Officer mieten.
Wat?
Chief Information Security Officer
as a Service.
Das ist quasi Personalvermittlung, oder?
Oder sowas?
Was kommt als nächstes? CEO as a
Service, oder wie?
Sowas will man sich doch nicht als a Service einkaufen.
Okay, was auch immer.
Eure Tochter, firmatisch, genau.
Okay, hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Also, dass man sich Security
Experten holt, für bestimmte Schwerpunkte,
von denen man selbst
nicht so viel Ahnung hat oder noch Know-How
aufbauen will in der Abteilung,
verstehe ich ja, aber den
Chef quasi davon?
Macht man das so?
Dann benutze ich lieber KEKW as a Service.
Aber seht ihr mal,
wahrscheinlich ist das ein ganz normales,
gar kein so mieses Unternehmen, wie es die
Stellenanzeige vermittelt.
Ey, diese Bilder,
das sind doch, die kenne ich doch.
Leute,
ich habe keine Ahnung, welches Projekt
das ist, aber die Bilder,
die Bilder sind doch von
einem dieser, hier kannst
du kostenlos, also
agile Webdesign
Bilder bekommen.
Das kommt mir übelst bekannt vor, diese Art von
Bildern.
Die kenne ich, die habe ich schon gesehen.
Stories?
Ja, kann sein, dass ich es da gesehen habe.
Werft es doch mal in die Google-Bildersuche
rein. Okay, mache ich.
Leute, ich kann euch den
geilsten Google-Hack aller Zeiten zeigen.
Guckt mal, ihr macht Google auf.
Geil, oder?
Da wärt ihr nicht drauf gekommen.
Aber gut, ich gebe zu,
das ist nicht das, was ich euch zeigen wollte.
Und zwar, man kann jetzt hier dieses Bild nehmen
und rein tracken und droppen
in Google.
Und da muss man es nicht zwischenspeichern.
Und dann kann man suchen danach
und findet,
diese Sorte von Bildern gibt es zu tausend
im Internet.
Andro,
ich glaube, da habe ich das her.
Ja, genau das meine ich.
Andro, exakt das habe ich
gemeint, die Seite.
Aber
daher kamen mir die Bilder bekannt
vor.
Aber das ist nicht wirklich exakt das, oder?
Es sieht aber schon sehr ähnlich aus.
Aber man sieht diese Bilder,
das ist halt einfach zugekauft.
Aber ganz im Ernst, die Stellenanzeige ist wahrscheinlich
viel schlechter als der Laden an sich.
Ich kann es jetzt nicht einschätzen,
aber ganz im Ernst, die Stellenanzeige ist mies.
Und das sieht doch jetzt eigentlich ganz brauchbar aus.
Also,
sofern man das von der Webseite schlussfolgern kann.
Geh mal auf
Unternehmenteam.
Moment, wait a minute.
Es sind eins, zwei, drei,
vier Leute.
Moment, die suchenden Admin
haben aber noch keinerlei
Technik zur Zeit.
Die haben
BWL-Frauen, Security-Kerl.
Okay, doch, ein Microsoft-Architekt
haben sie am Start.
Das ist ja ein Bogus.
Gibt es nicht eine .NET-Library,
die so heißt,
um Fake-Daten zu generieren?
Weiß nicht, wie ich da jetzt gerade drauf komme.
IT-Support.
Okay, die suchen quasi noch einen fünften Mitarbeiter.
Dann stimmt das hier tatsächlich,
was sie schreiben, mit attraktiver Start-up-Atmosphäre.
Aber die Stellenanzeige ist trotzdem nicht gut.
Also, durchaus möglich, dass das gar kein
schlechtes Unternehmen ist, aber die Stellenanzeige ist halt
richtig mies.
Wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben?
Ich bin beim Chat bei 20.31 Uhr.
Wir haben jetzt 21.01 Uhr.
Bin 30 Minuten im Chat hinten dran.
Ich suche eine Postman-Alternative.
Habt ihr eine Empfehlung für mich?
Ja, wenn du besonders woke bist,
dann benutzt du Postwoman.
Ach nee, Hopscotch heißt das jetzt.
Okay, die haben sich umbenannt.
Die heißen gar nicht mehr Postwoman.
Aber die gibt's auch noch.
Ich hab mir das
nur gemerkt, weil es damals
auf Hacker-News stand irgendwie.
Warum gibt es nur Postman?
Wir haben jetzt auch ein neues Projekt Postwoman.
Ich hab mich damals gefragt, okay, wenn der Name
der einzige Grund ist dafür, dass ich eine andere Software
benutzen soll, dann benutze ich
wahrscheinlich keine andere Software.
Und mir wäre es sogar initial egal gewesen,
ob ich ursprünglich Postman
oder Postwoman benutzt hätte.
Aber ich hätte nicht einfach nur dem Namen halber
die Software gewechselt.
Insomnia? Das kenne ich gar nicht.
Also, es gibt übrigens auch
für Visual Studio ganz nette
so REST-Plugins,
wo man vieles mit machen kann.
Insomnia.
GitHub?
Oder was such ich da am besten?
Thunderclient.
So.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich bin Team Curl.
Kong.
Okay, das kenne ich nicht.
Oh, das ist garantiert eine Elektronen-Anwendung.
Chat, warum benutzt man nicht einfach Curl?
Okay, ehrlich gesagt,
ich weiß, warum man nicht einfach Curl benutzt,
weil du hast ja natürlich mehr Features,
die du mit Curl nicht hast.
Du kannst dir irgendwelche Sessions speichern,
du kannst dir irgendwelche Templates speichern,
du kannst eingebaut CraftQL,
WebSocket und all das kann Curl alles nicht.
Ja.
Also Sachen, die nur HTTP sind,
warum nicht einfach Curl?
Lass mal die Git-Diskussion.
Ach so, soll ich erzählen, nur CLI-Curl ist gut,
alle anderen UIs sind kacke?
Nee, bei Curl sehe ich das aber nicht so.
Man kann auch Wget verwenden.
Postman benutze ich selbst manchmal.
Okay, ich muss mal mit dem Chat jetzt
vorbeikommen,
sonst wird das ja gar nicht.
Echt, Windows kann doch ohne Probleme
ein NTP-Query machen
und sich sünken am Anfang.
Ich meine, es gibt ja zwei Möglichkeiten,
wie du es mit NTP machen kannst.
Du kannst entweder die Zeit sünken
und hart setzen beim Systemstart
oder, tja, wann auch immer du willst.
Oder du lässt im Hintergrund
halt ein NTP-Service laufen,
der die Zeit langsam
ein bisschen driften lässt,
mal ein bisschen langsamer,
mal ein bisschen schneller,
so dass du immer in der Zeit bist.
Das kommt aber noch aus Zeiten,
wo Software manchmal nicht richtig
damit klargekommen ist,
wenn die Zeit springt.
Mag sicherlich Software geben,
wo das heute noch so ist,
aber normalerweise braucht man es
nicht unbedingt.
Ich weiß, dass es richtig 3 hat.
Ich war heute beim Friseur
und ich gehe bei uns
in Frankfurt um die Ecke
zu so einem türkischen Friseur
und der hat heute
einen Spruch gebracht.
Also, als erstes mal
die unstrittige Sache.
Der hat mich heute so
vollgeschüttet mit ihrem komischen
nach Zitrone riechenden
Wasser,
dass mein ganzes Hemd jetzt nach Zitrone riecht.
Die sind ja immer super
ordentlich dort.
Da wird auch immer die Kontur noch mit dem Rasiermesser
und so alles nachgeschärft.
Danach kriegt man
so ein bisschen
Desinfektionsmittel
oder sowas ist das.
Es brennt auch, wenn du es
in den Nacken kriegst, wenn er da
ordentlich rasiert hat.
Und
da hat er irgendwie die halbe Flasche
mir ins Genick geschüttet heute.
Das ganze Hemd riecht nur nach Zitrone.
Aber jetzt kommt
ähm
jetzt kommt ein Spruch, wo ich mir denke
hätte ich den als Deutscher gebracht,
da hätten sie mich alle scharf angeguckt.
Ich zitiere meinen Friseur, wo ich gewesen bin.
Muss
man ja immer dazu sagen.
Und zwar, das ist halt so ein ganz
kleiner türkischer Friseurladen,
wie es in Frankfurt viele gibt.
Da kommst du rein, hast dann irgendwie so
sieben Sitze oder so und ganz
genauso viele Friseure, ja.
So und ich sitze halt bei einem und er macht mir so
die Haare und ich sehe halt
so schräg gegenüber
chillt halt einer von den Friseuren.
Der hat halt gerade keinen Kunden gehabt oder so.
Ich hab halt mal kurz zu dem
rüber geguckt, so was der da macht.
Einfach gucken, ob ich den hier schon mal gesehen habe oder so.
Ähm und da meinte
mein Friseur zu mir, wundere dich
nicht, das ist Araber, der arbeitet
nie. Und da hab ich mir gedacht, okay.
Hätte ich
den Spruch gebracht,
wär ich schon aus gewesen, ey.
Aber das ist halt
kein Ding gewesen, ja.
Ich find das ja auch überhaupt nicht schlimm.
Die sollen sich ruhig ein bisschen die Sprüche
reindrücken gegenseitig.
Ich bin ja bei so was
nicht so.
Ich kann auch über mich selbst lachen.
Ich bin auch nicht getriggert, wenn
einer Witze über dicke Leute macht oder so.
Ich bin ja nicht mehr dick jetzt seit
2 Jahren. Naja.
Doch, ich bin schon auch zu dick.
Ich hab
damit überhaupt keine Schmerzen.
Aber wenn du jemand bist, der bei allem super
krass getriggert ist, also
der hat halt gelacht,
hab ich halt auch gelacht. Okay, ja, dann war gut.
Der andere hat auch gelacht, fertig.
Wenn du halt super kritisch drauf
bist, hättest du dich jetzt gefragt,
kann ich bei so einer Aussage überhaupt mit
lachen? Darf ich jetzt? Darf ich das?
Muss es echt
sich übertreiben? Ich denke, man
muss in alle Richtungen
auch ein bisschen was einstecken können.
Es sollte nicht bösartig sein.
Dann denke ich, irgendwann kann man
mit Sprüchen auch eine gewisse
Grenze überschreiten, wo man es nicht unbedingt
jetzt
noch weiter treiben muss.
Aber ich denke, alle Seiten würden mal,
und ich denke da auch gerade an Twitter und Social
Media, alle Seiten würden glaube ich mal
ganz gut dran tun, wenn sie über
sich selbst und andere Sachen auch mal ein bisschen mehr
reden könnten.
Ich halte das aus, wenn einer blöde Sprüche
über mich macht.
Natürlich nicht, wie gesagt, ganzen Tag
24-7 und dann auch unter der
Gürtellinie, das nicht.
Dann rege ich mich auch auf.
Aber ansonsten, wenn ab und zu mal irgendwie
einer einen blöden Spruch macht, hab ich überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit.
Und umgedreht, finde ich,
sollte man es auch mal abkönnen,
wenn man irgendeinen blöden Spruch reinkriegt.
Ist ein Unterschied, ob's... Ja, das ist
natürlich nochmal ein anderer Unterschied. Na klar.
Wenn du von Freunden irgendwelche blöden
Sprüche reinkriegst, da kannst du ja teilweise...
Unter Freunden kann man teilweise richtig krasse Dinger
sich an den Kopf schmeißen und keinen
stört's richtig.
Das ist kein Ding. Ne, aber ich meine auch so
allgemein. Man muss sich nicht
bei jedem Furz, den irgendwo
irgendeiner gesagt hat, gleich
auf Twitter und überall empören darüber.
Oh, ganz schlimm, was der gesagt hat. Super schlecht
der Mensch. Lass mal direkt beim Arbeitgeber
anrufen, dass er den kündigt und so. Gibt's ja so
Aufrufe auf Twitter, ne? Also die haben ja echt
einen Dachschaden. Ich finde, das müssten alle mal
ein bisschen was aushalten können.
Im Rahmen selbstverständlich, ja.
Okay, komm mal weiter.
Komische Sachen also. Ach so, ja gut.
Vielleicht, wenn's bei mir irgendwann auch mal
reinkickt, dass ich
sage, oh fuck, ich bin jetzt 40
plus, mein Leben ist bald zu Ende in 40
Jahren, dass ich dann sage,
ich mach jetzt was Blödes, ich geh zu Kik.
Wer weiß. Aktuell find ich Kik allerdings
keine für mich interessante Plattform.
Vielleicht nicht.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist hoch, 100%
sicher ist nix. Leute, ihr könnt euch merken,
dass die allerwenigsten Sachen
100%
sicher sind, also
100% wahrscheinlich oder 0%
unwahrscheinlich. Alle Sachen,
die so tagtäglich passieren, liegen irgendwo
dazwischen. Oder auch Sachen, die
nicht passieren. Also die meisten Sachen
liegen irgendwo dazwischen, zwischen 0 und 100%.
Es gibt Sachen, die sind extrem,
extrem wahrscheinlich, aber die
allermeisten davon sind nicht
100%. Also es könnte auch sein,
dass jetzt gleich ein Flugzeug bei euch aufs Haus fällt.
Sehr unwahrscheinlich,
aber nicht ausgeschlossen.
Es könnte auch sein, dass ihr vom Messerturm in
Frankfurt springt und das überlebt. Sehr unwahrscheinlich,
aber nicht ausgeschlossen.
Es könnte auch sein, dass bald
irgendwelche Aliens landen.
Auch sehr unwahrscheinlich, aber nicht ausgeschlossen.
Oh, das ist natürlich
ähm, sad game.
Ja, ist auch, ist auch ein bisschen so.
Zu 100% ausgeschlossen ist,
dass der Cheat 95 Milliardär wird.
Nein, das ist auch nicht zu 100% ausgeschlossen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich nie passieren,
aber das ist definitiv nicht zu 100% ausgeschlossen.
Wie gesagt, das meiste ist
nicht zu 100% ausgeschlossen oder zu 100%
sicher. Es gibt,
wir, wir, wir, ohne, ohne,
dass es, dass man es wirklich realisiert,
ist man eigentlich den ganzen Tag
mit sehr vielen Wahrscheinlichkeiten
konfrontiert.
Wovon manche Sachen doch sehr, sehr, sehr
wahrscheinlich sind und manche Sachen doch sehr, sehr
wahrscheinlich. Aber die wenigsten Sachen
sind 0 oder 100. Und schon gar nicht
101, wie manche umgangssprachlich
sagen. Oder
200% oder so.
Das ist 200% sicher.
Nein, nee. Das,
die 100 mehr machen es jetzt auch
nicht aus. Das ist halt schon wieder negativ.
Das passiert schon wieder nicht.
Ja, ist so. Sage ich ja auch.
Ganz im Ernst,
wir leben ja nicht,
um nur zu arbeiten.
Oder die, die
sich zu viel KLS-Videos
angeguckt haben, dass sie auf den Mount Everest
müssen und den ganzen Tag hustlen und halt
sein Zeug verkaufen, dass er fett Kohle verdient,
oder irgendwelche anderen Coaches,
vollkommen wurscht.
Mag Leute geben, die sind da Meinung,
dass sie, aber ehrlich gesagt,
die Leute, die in diese Gruppen gehen,
das sind ja gar nicht die, die super krass
husteln wollen. Das sind die, die easy money machen
wollen, weil ihnen das
vordergründig versprochen wird.
Naja,
unterm Strich muss man
gut leben können von dem, was man verdient.
Und mehr
muss eigentlich nicht sein. Die restliche
Zeit sollte man nutzen, möglichst
viel in seinem Leben das zu machen, worauf man
Bock hat.
Jetzt mal ganz allgemein ausgedrückt.
Ich meine, das kann sein, dass man Zeit mit
Leuten verbringt, die man gerne hat,
von Freunde bis Familie, oder halt, dass man
irgendwelchen Hobbys nachgeht, oder sich neue
Sachen anguckt. Deswegen sage ich es mal ganz allgemein.
Ja, Zeit mit Sachen verbringen,
die einem wichtig sind, worauf man Bock hat.
Und man muss nicht
mehr arbeiten, als nötig ist, dass man halbwegs
gescheit über die Runden kommt
und alles machen kann, was man will.
Okay, das nehme ich zurück. Man muss nicht
alles machen können,
was man will.
Weil, kann man sagen, ja, ich würde auch gerne mal
ins Weltall fliegen, aber das kostet halt
pro Person relativ teuer. Relativ viel
Geld ist relativ teuer. Da muss man sich halt
überlegen, okay, was ist denn realistisch?
Was will ich machen?
Wenn du sagst, ey, ich will ins Weltall,
ja, dann 24-7
reinhustlen
und
Start-up gründen und Start-up für Millionen
verkaufen. Easy. Naja, Moment.
Madminister, du warst am Anfang
nicht da. Es ging um Leute,
die überhaupt kein Foto
auf ihren Lebenslauf
machen wollten. Und dazu
habe ich gesagt, doch, ich finde,
das gehört dazu und es kommt einfach besser
an. Gerade, wenn es ein halbwegs sympathisches
Foto ist. Und natürlich ist ein
richtig gutes Foto noch besser als
irgendwie so ein billig
selbstgemachtes Foto. Aber es ist
immer noch besser, als gar kein Foto
draufzupappen. Natürlich, wie gesagt,
es muss kein super Gammelfoto aus dem Keller
sein, aus einem beschissenen Winkel.
Aber man kann auch mit einem iPhone
gescheite Bilder machen, wenn man nirgends
wohin will. Aber ja, das stimmt schon. Ich würde dir
Recht geben, das lohnt sich tatsächlich.
Weil dein erster Eindruck, den die Leute haben,
dass es ein sympathisches Foto ist,
macht einfach einen viel besseren, netteren
Eindruck. Und wenn die mehrere Leute zur Auswahl
haben, was ja in der IT glücklicherweise
nicht so oft vorkommt,
dann hast du gute Karten damit.
Direkt verklagen.
Bäm. Du musst jetzt direkt getriggert
sein. Das ist, das macht man heutzutage
so. Du musst direkt getriggert
sein und sagen, dass sie dich Fatshamed haben
und die verklagen. Und direkt
Name droppen auf Twitter und sagen,
die haben mich Fatshamed und deswegen habe ich den Job nicht
bekommen und Anzeige ist raus.
Ich verklage jetzt.
Aber ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube
nicht, dass das was miteinander zu tun hat.
Und mal ganz davon abgesehen, ist
die Frage meines Wissens nach auch
gar nicht erlaubt.
Ich glaube, du darfst einen Bewerber
so Sachen gar nicht fragen.
Du darfst einen Bewerber auch nicht
fragen, sind sie gerade schwanger
oder haben sie vor, demnächst schwanger zu werden.
Was heißt, du darfst den Bewerber nicht fragen?
Du darfst es auch einen Mitarbeiter meines
Wissens nach gar nicht fragen.
Also das ist tatsächlich was, wo ich mir Gedanken
machen würde, warum fragt die mich sowas?
Das ist wahrscheinlich ein Scheißladen,
wenn die nicht wissen, dass man sowas
nicht gehört. Wenn die Krankheit
berufsrelevant ist. Okay, du könntest
sagen, ja,
jemand, der im Gastronomiebereich
arbeitet, sollte gerade keine übertragbaren
Magen-Darm-Erkrankungen haben.
Das sind so Dinger, die kann ich irgendwie noch
nachvollziehen. Nee, habe ich nicht
verwendet, aber
wir hatten letztens so eine
Einführungsveranstaltung für neue Mitarbeiter
und da sollte jeder
auf so eine Tafel schreiben
so kleine Facts zu sich
und da gab es zwei Sachen,
also Name und Foto
und so war da drauf, da gab es einmal
Funfact über mich und
das ist meine Superkraft und da sollte man
halt irgendwie so einen super geistreichen
Satz hinschreiben und
da hat jemand draufgeschrieben
von den anderen
Wie gekotzt von Alkohol
Das würde ich doch nicht da draufschreiben
Also
ich weiß nicht
ich weiß nicht, wie wenig
Feingefühl man haben muss, um
auf eine öffentliche
Pinnwand, dort wo man
arbeitet, bei Funfact
sowas draufzuschreiben.
Ich meine, klar,
wenn es der Richtige liest, mag ganz
lustig sein, aber ich glaube, das
kommt nicht gut
an. Also ich habe
draufgeschrieben, I use Arch by the way
als meine
Superkraft
Hat wahrscheinlich außer zwei Leuten
niemand verstanden
Hat jemand eigentlich Feedback
zu dem Spruch? Nö
Das würde komplett totgeschwiegen
Das wäre witzig gewesen
Hätte irgendeiner dort von den Bewerbern
oder Bewerberinnen draufgeschrieben
By the way, ich bin bei
Onlyfans
Ich meine, in der heutigen
Zeit, nicht so unwahrscheinlich
das von
sagen wir mal
Wie viele Leute werden das gewesen
sein? Das waren schon
Ja, sagen wir mal so
60 Leute
Dass davon vielleicht irgendjemand Onlyfans
hatte, so unwahrscheinlich
in der heutigen Zeit nicht mal
Du benutzt Astroneowim
Jetzt wird es aber abgedreht
Und was ist denn mit
Ich habe vergessen, wie das heißt
Ich habe letztens in so einem Video
was über irgend so eine andere
NeoWim Distribution gesehen
Ich mag das nicht, ich richte das
wenn überhaupt am liebsten selbst ein
Ich bin jetzt fast 40 Minuten hintendran
im Chat, meine Güte, das geht glaube ich
Ich muss mich mal ein bisschen beeilen
Du hättest bei Funfact mein Twitch
Nee, will ich ja nicht, dass das irgendjemand kennt
Deswegen ist bei Bewerbung
meistens auch jemand von der Personalabteilung dabei
Außerdem sollte jemand in der Führungsposition
der regelmäßig Bewerbungsgespräche
Vorstellungsgespräche führt
wissen, dass man Leute nicht nach
Diabetes oder Krankheiten fragt
Falls du noch eine Reviewen möchtest
da kriege ich den restlichen Chat heute aber nicht durch
Okay, Backend Developer
Woah, mein Auge
Okay, gleich viel besser
Naja, passt
Backend Developer
bei Wirt IT
Von denen habe ich schon mal was gehört
Ich könnte es jetzt nicht genau
zuordnen, aber
der Name
sagt mir was
Werkzeug? Sind das die gleichen
die Werkzeug machen?
Okay, der globale IT-Dienstleister für die
Wirt-Gruppe
Mit über 1000 IT-Spezialisten
Okay, bla bla bla
Das schenken wir uns mal, okay
Inklusive
Home-Mobile-Working-Anteil
suchen sie
einen Backend-Developer
männlich-weiß-deutsch
wieder
Let's do IT
Das sind echt so
übelst ausgelutschte Sprüche
Du spürst den Herzschlag
des Wirt-Konzerns jeden Tag
hautnah
Das klingt mir jetzt fast schon ein bisschen zu aufdringlich
Aber lesen wir mal weiter
Denn dein Team
und du entwickeln, betreuen und unterstützen
tausende Außendienst-Mitarbeiter
Außendienst-Mitarbeitende
bei ihrer täglichen Arbeit
mit weltweit angesehenen Außendienstlösungen
Wie, Leute?
Man unterstützt Außendienst-Mitarbeiter mit
Außendienstlösungen
Da wäre ich jetzt nicht drauf
Das wäre mir entgangen
Mit weltweit
nicht angesehenen
angehenden
Die meinen angesehenen, oder?
Nicht angehenden
Weil angehenden
ergibt doch in dem Kontext
überhaupt keinen Sinn
Und dein Team analysieren
konzipieren, entwickeln, funktioniert
zur Anbindung
Wieso du als Backend-Developer
Außendienst-Mitarbeitende
betreust, ist auch eine
berechtigte Frage, Chat
Ergibt auch wenig Sinn
Du und dein Team analysieren, konzipieren, entwickeln
Die wollen damit wahrscheinlich sagen
Dass du
Die haben betreuen verwendet
Betreuen ist wahrscheinlich das falsche Wort
Und unterstützen auch
Die meinen wahrscheinlich, du sorgst dafür
durch deine gute Software
dass die Außendienst-Mitarbeitenden gut arbeiten können
Das ist ein bisschen blöd geschrieben
Ich gehe davon aus, dass sie das meinen
Ansonsten müsste da irgendwas
Relativ sicher
Vielleicht meinen sie es auch wörtlich
Aber ich glaube, die meinen das eher so, wie ich gesagt habe
Und dein Team analysieren, konzipieren, entwickeln
Der im gesamten Wirt-Konzern
eingesetzten Selbstlösung
Residenz-Sleeper, Alter
Du bist kreativ und
motiviert, innovative und
effiziente Prozesse für die Unterstützung des
Wirt-Außendienst zu etablieren
Leute
Wer schreibt diese
Stellenanzeigen immer?
Habt ihr jemals schon gedacht, wenn euch was
auf der Arbeit auf den Keks gegangen ist
Und ihr so überlegt habt
Ach
Ich würde mich nicht vielleicht mal nach einem Job umgucken
Aber was würde mich denn mal
so wirklich interessieren
Und habt ihr da nicht auch schon mal gedacht
Oh ja, jetzt weiß ich es
Ich möchte kreativ und motiviert
innovativ und effiziente Prozesse
für die Unterstützung des
Außendienst etablieren
Wer schreibt
diese Dinger immer, man
Täglich gedacht, ja, klar
Du fungierst als Ansprechperson
für neue Herausforderungen, entwickelns
bestehende Lösungen und neue
Hä? Alter, wer schreibt
diese Sätze, man
Was zum Teufel soll das überhaupt bedeuten?
Ich bin Backend-Entwickler
Du fungierst
als Ansprechperson
für neue Anforderungen, entwickelns
bestehende Lösungen und neue Anforderungen
Okay, okay, die meinen
damit wahrscheinlich, also ich rate das
jetzt einfach mal, du bist Backend-Developer
Du arbeitest halt an der Software
so, und wenn irgendjemand
eine coole Idee hat oder eine
Anforderung, dann kommt
er zu dir und fragt, ob man das einbauen
kann, und du machst das dann
irgendwie möglich, so
Wobei es für sowas
eigentlich, weil sie ja effiziente und innovative
Prozesse angeben, zumindest
eine wie geartete
äh, wie wie gearteten auch
immer, ähm
Prozess für geben sollte, wie man
neue Features und neue Funktionen
beauftragt, weil ansonsten
wird's wir
Dann kommt dann irgendein Typ zu dir
Ich kenn das, ich hab das erlebt, ja
Also wenn sowas
nicht geregelt ist
unter anderem auch, muss ja nicht, sowas wie ein
Ticketsystem, dass das nachvollziehbar ist, wer, wie, wo
wann, wie, was beauftragt hat
Dann passiert folgendes, ich kann euch das genau
ich kann euch genau erklären, was passiert, ich kenn das aus eigener
Erfahrung
Dann kommt irgendein Typ zu dir und
sagt, hey, wir müssen mal schnell
auf nem Produktiv-Server
die Config anpassen
weil da geht irgendwas nicht
oder da muss irgendwas gemacht werden aus diesen
und diesen Gründen, dann sagst du, ja, aber das ist ein Produktiv-Server
da brauchen wir ein Change für
Ja, aber das ist
Wunsch, das ist eine
Herzensangelegenheit unseres IT-Vorstands
dass wir das machen
und dann bist du in der Position, da musst du
sagen, okay
eigentlich dürfte ich das
jetzt nicht
aber es gibt ja keinen so richtig guten
Prozess dafür, das heißt
will ich jetzt wirklich was sagen dagegen
dass unser IT-Chef
das will, ja
und das sind so Dinger, die willst du nicht, dass die passieren
Wenn es
die Vorgabe gibt, du brauchst
ein Change
für Produktions
Anpassung, unter diesen
und diesen Ausnahmen
gibt es vielleicht andere Möglichkeiten
dann muss sich auch ein
IT-Vorstand daran halten
es sei denn
er setzt das ganze außer Kraft
wofür es ja in einem ordentlichen Prozess bestimmt
auch irgendwelche Möglichkeiten gibt
aber du darfst nie der Gearschte
sein, wenn du dich
an die Vorgaben hältst
die
quasi deine Führungskräfte
dir für deine Arbeit gemacht haben
weil ansonsten stellst du ja automatisch
jegliche Entscheidung
immer in Frage
also wenn du heute was gesagt
kriegst und morgen
das wieder revoked
wird von irgendjemandem, dem es heute
nicht passt
dann kannst du ja überhaupt keine gesicherte
Entscheidung und Arbeit mehr machen
deswegen ist
das wichtig
und wenn es sowas nicht gibt
oder wenn es
gerne, sagen wir mal
dynamisch gehandhabt wird, was ja auch
vollkommen okay ist und gerade bei Projekten
auch vollkommen okay ist
solange es nicht wirklich um Live Deployments
in Produktion und sowas geht
dann muss es aber zumindest
eine Anforderung geben
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
auch immer, wo das nachvollziehbar ist
weil in dieser Anforderung kannst
du dann sagen, wenn jetzt zum Beispiel
einer zu mir kommt und sagt, hey Max
du musst mal ganz schnell in Produktion in der Config-Datei was
ändern, weil
der IT-Abteilungsleiter hat das
gesagt, da werde ich natürlich
nicht sagen, oh ne oder kann mich mal, das mache ich
dann würde ich sagen, schreibe das mal
ins Ticket und
dann schreibe ich in das Ticket meine
Bedenken rein, wenn ich welche habe
zum Beispiel, vielleicht gab es bei
ähnlichen Konfigurationen in der Vergangenheit schon mal Probleme
schreibe ich das rein und irgendjemand
mein Chef, sein Chef
irgendjemand, der da was zu sagen hat
muss den Scheiß abnicken
wenn ich Bedenken habe, sonst würde ich es
schlicht und ergreifend nicht machen
es gibt immer Ausnahmen
man darf das nicht
zu steif sehen
im gewissen Ermessensspielraum sollte es immer geben
also wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
sehe
wie, jetzt mal ein ganz
übertriebenes Beispiel
wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel sehe
wie gerade einer mit einem Kran
sich abseilt
in unser Rechenzentrum
um Festplatten zu klauen
dass ich dann
den Strom
ausschalte
weil alles encrypted ist
so ganz abgedrehte Fälle
du hast immer noch irgendwie Art und Weise
in den Spielraum
aber es macht keinen Sinn
Prozesse zu etablieren und permanent
dagegen zu verstoßen, wisst ihr wie ich mein?
und das ist halt das
wo ich mir auch denken würde
Anforderungen und mal neue
Themen besprechen mit einem Backendentwickler
überhaupt kein Ding
bevor man irgendwie einen Auftrag macht mal zu klären
ist das technisch möglich, wie macht das Sinn
das ist überhaupt kein Problem
aber das darf nicht an einem Entwickler
am Ende hängen
ihr habt Prozesse, ich arbeite bei einer Versicherung
wir sind bürokratisch als Fakt
wir haben Prozesse für nahezu alles
und die dauern ewig teilweise
wenn du eine neue Software auf deinem Notebook
haben willst, braucht es drei Monate
wenn du Pech hast, kriegst du sie nicht
deswegen bin ich froh, dass ich ein Linux-VM habe, auf der ich gut bin
ja gut, aber nur so ein kleiner
kleiner Exkurs
du hast immer einen Blick für neue Trends
du hast immer neue, innovative Lösungen
du bist bereit, diese mit
ja okay, 0815
also mal ernsthaft
das ist so langweilig 0815
vage geschrieben
also es würde mich jetzt nicht sonderlich ansprechen
Toilettenbesuch
also du wirst lachen
wir haben sicherlich keine Regeln zum Toilettenbesuch
aber wir haben sicherlich
irgendwelche Regeln
die das prinzipiell mit einschließen
wir haben dann
einen IT
Moment, wie heißt das?
Sekunde
ich hab hier irgendwo
so einen IT
ähm
Bereichshandbuch heißt das
glaube ich
das hat über 500 Seiten
und
da sind schon
ziemlich viele allgemeine Sachen
zu geregelt und also
mich würde es
ich würde es nicht wundern
wenn da nicht irgendwo steht, so sinngemäß
äh man darf keine
USB-Sticks und Datenträger in der Toilette
entsorgen und sowas
das würde mich ernsthaft nicht wundern
in dem Laden, wenn die sowas geregelt hätten
explizit
das würde mich echt nicht wundern
jede Regel hat eine Geschichte
ja vielleicht hatten die auch mal so ein spezialer
Zubi, dem sein Handy ins Klo gefallen ist
und hat es nicht mehr rausgekriegt
die Geschichte kennt ihr aber
ich kann euch keine Stories erzählen heute, ich komm schon mit dem Chat eh nicht hinterher
okay
bring IT on
jetzt lasst uns mal kurz das hier abschließen
du bist kreativ, wissbegierig und befasst
dich mit aktuellen Trends
hast Lust, Dinge zu bewegen und neue Impulse zu geben
du möchtest, dass dein Einsatz und dein Know-How
erkannt und geschätzt werden
klingt ja sinnvoll alles, ja
finden wir klasse, wenn du noch folgende Punkte mitbringst
sollten wir uns kennenlernen
du hast Lust, klingt ja ein bisschen wie bei Parship fast schon
du hast Lust
du hast Lust, mit uns neue Wege in die Cloud zu gehen
ja, klingt schon mal deutlich besser
als das Geschwurbel da oben
du hast dann abgeschlossen
hast Freude
an der Entwicklung
von High-Performance-Enterprise-Schnittstellen
Alter
mehr
Generic
was man macht, hättet ihr nicht schreiben können, oder?
oh ja, ich entwickle so gerne
High-Performance-Enterprise-Schnittstellen
ihr nicht auch, Leute
also
morgens entwickle ich gerne
High-Performance-Enterprise-Schnittstellen
und abends bin ich gerne kreativ
und motiviert, innovative und effiziente
Prozesse für die Unterstützung des Außendienstes
zu etablieren
richtig geil, das wünsche ich mir
schon immer
Leute, also
die Stellenanzeigenschreiber schreibt da doch
irgendwas bisschen handfestes
hin
das ist ja
schlechter als Chat-GPT
na gut, bringst gute
Kenntnisse
im C-Sharp, Leute
im Scharf-See
die haben nicht ernsthaft
im Scharf-Seen damit gemeint, oder?
bringst gute Kenntnisse
im C-Sharp?
da hat doch irgendjemand
nicht gecheckt, dass damit nicht Scharf-Seen
gemeint ist, oder?
das wusste ich halt, du bringst gute
Kenntnisse in C-Sharp
in der Leistung, sowie in der objektorientierten
Softwareentwicklung mit
objektorientiert ist doch eh out
wer schreibt denn sowas heute?
heute bist du cool, wenn du Sachen funktional machen kannst
zu objektorientiert dabei
erstmal den Bewerber
Rust-Pattern-Matching-Aufgabe
lösen lassen
im Scharf? Nein, Leute, wir wissen alle, dass das
C-Latten-Zaun ist
hast du Erfahrungen mit Datenbanken
wie PostgreSQL und MSSQL?
Ja
Nein
oder C-Pwned-Sein geht auch
hast du idealerweise bereits Erfahrungen
mit Docker und Kubernetes? Ja
bringst gute Deutsch-Englisch-Kenntnisse
mit? Oh, ja, exzellente
Englisch-Kenntnisse
Teil eines globalen Konzerns, dennoch
familiär
ganz ehrlich, das ist einfach immer bla bla bla
gelaber, im Endeffekt ist das
Business für beide Seiten
international ausgehend dennoch
bla bla bla
bla bla bla bla
alter, freu dich auf spannende Aufgaben
ja ok, mobile work bis zu 80%
im Monat
ok, das ist eine Ansage, finde ich nice
umfangreiches Onboarding-Einarbeitungsprogramm
ja gut, das ist jetzt
jetzt ist es jetzt, sag mal so
ja, das ist schon durchaus
ein Vorteil für mich, aber hauptsächlich auch
wenn ich gut eingearbeitet werde
ein Vorteil für das Unternehmen
und das sollte eigentlich selbstverständlich sein
nichts, was ich als super krasses Benefit sehen würde
Weiterbildungsmöglichkeiten
tja, ok
unbefristetes Arbeitsverhältnis, ja das wünschen die sich
sicherlich, die wollen nicht, dass die Leute abhauen
flexible Arbeitszeitmodelle
kann gut, kann schlecht sein, so wie die es hier oben
geschrieben haben, klingt ganz gut
für die hohle Hand
wichtig, also vollkommen egal
kommt drauf an, wie das gelebt
wird dort, vielfältige
Karriereprogramme und Perspektiven, tja, kommt auch
drauf an
Mitarbeitervertretung, Erfolgszulage, schonmal nicht verkehrt
Mitarbeitervertretung
hä?
so nach dem Motto, wenn ich
in Urlaub fahre, macht jemand meinen Job oder
oder Mitarbeiter, ach ne, die meinen
Betriebsrat, meinen sie sowas wie Betriebsrat?
die meinen Betriebsrat, gell
ja
hab mich grad etwas verwirrt
die meinen sowas wie Betriebsrat
ich glaub bei uns nennt sich das Ganze auch
Betriebsrat, aber wenn du bei uns
hochfährst und auf
auf den
Wegweiser guckst, steht glaub ich bei uns auch
Mitarbeitervertretung
Mitarbeiter, Shop, Mitarbeiter
und Kulturevent, oah
Jubiläumsfeier
wie sagt man, wie oft
haben die denn Jubiläum?
Jedes Jahr ein Jahr älter, oder wie?
Treue Prämie, Geburts-
und Heiratsbeihilfen
Jobrat,
Fahrsicherheitstraining, Jobticket, okay
warum nicht, die hauen einfach mal alles drauf
Gesundheitsprogramme, kostenlose Heiz- und kalte Getränke
Zuschuss des Betriebsrats
das ist gut, das ist gut
Leute, ihr glaubt gar nicht
das ist echt von Vorteil
Betriebskrankenkasse
Mitarbeiter, Werbemitarbeiterprogramm
ja, die haben einfach mal alles draufgehauen
okay, Leute
die Stellenanzeige ist richtig mies, die gefällt mir überhaupt nicht
das Unternehmen kann trotzdem
gut sein, aber die
Stellenanzeige, also gerade
gerade der erste, das erste
das ist wirklich schlechter, als wie es hätte
ChatGPT schreiben können
und hier unten hatte ich auch so meine Zweifel, ob derjenige, der die
Stellenanzeige erstellt hat, wirklich wusste, was er da reinschreibt
ja
sagt nichts über das Unternehmen aus, aber
wir können es ja nur anhand der Stellenanzeige jetzt beurteilen
und die fand ich echt mies
Bewerbung ist raus, inklusive
Verbesserungsvorschlag, oh ja
das würde mich interessieren, wenn das
jemand macht, was die da drauf schreiben
weil
entweder sind das so, wie soll man
sagen
welche, die es halt nicht abkönnen, dass
einer da was
vorschlägt und die Meinung sind, dass ihre Arbeit
perfekt ist, oder
sie laden dich erst recht ein
und finden das ganz spannend
das würde mich echt interessieren, ja, wie die
drauf sind, okay Leute, ich muss jetzt
jetzt, ich werde jetzt mal etwas
schneller den Chat scrollen und nur
mir die Sachen angucken, wie etwa Bloss
dabei steht, weil das sind ja die, wo explizit
jemand was von mir will, oder gefragt hat
es gibt auch Lizenzpakete, ja gut, warum auch nicht
aber das Ding heißt jetzt
offiziell Microsoft 365
warum hast du das gepostet, achso
darf ich dir eine Stellenanzeige reinsenden
Bewerbung IQ Solutions
Systemadministrator, okay, komm
wir gucken uns das schnell nochmal rein, wir haben noch
eine halbe Stunde Zeit, hey, die Bilder
kommen uns doch irgendwie bekannt vor
wait a minute, haben wir mehr solcher Bilder
ne
das ist doch auch wieder so
gleiches Bild dieser Art
okay, wir müssen das mal kurz
im anderen Browser aufmachen, weil
Darkreader
neugierig, was deine Vorteile als
Systemadministrator bei uns sind, ja ich hoffe
dass ich Geld bekomme und nicht mehr unter der Brücke schlafen
muss, das wäre schon mal
ein nicer Vorteil, finde ich auch
ab sofort in Vollzeit, oh shit
ja, absolut
die Seite
ist nicht schlecht gemacht
finde ich gut, die Seite
optisch finde ich diese Stellenanzeige
schon mal deutlich
besser und angenehmer
als die letzte, Design ist gut gemacht
okay, also, offenbar
boah, erster Minuspunkt
ne
ist egal, okay, mobiles, beziehungsweise
Homeoffice möglich, schon mal gut
so sieht dein Tag bei uns aus, du bist
ein wichtiger Teil unseres IT Support Teams
ach ne, Leute, ach ne
ach ne
muss es
muss es schon echt so anfangen, ja
das ist nicht, dass es
schlechter Job ist oder schlechter Arbeit gäbe
aber das ist halt das, wo ich mit Abstand am
wenigsten Bock drauf hätte, gut
bei mich persönlich ist eh egal, ich hab nen Job
und aktuell bin ich auch noch sehr happy
so sieht dein Tag
bei uns aus, du bist ein wichtiger Teil unseres
IT Support Teams und optimierst
Kundensystem in Firstans, ach ne
ach wirklich, muss das denn
echt sein, du bist
innovativ und evaluierst und implementierst
ebenso innovative Lösungen für unsere Kunden
okay, das ist halt auch super generic
0815, das kann einfach alles bedeuten
und ernsthaft
wenn man in der Bewerbung
gefragt wird, sind sie innovativ
wer würde dann sagen
oh ne, ich hasse Innovation, Alter
geht mir weg mit neuem Kram
natürlich sagt man dann das, was sie hören
wollen und ich kann sagen
guck bei mir einfach ins Twitch Archiv
dann siehst du, wie innovativ wir hier sind
aber das ist ja auch nur wegen High IQ Chat
du weißt, dass es bei der Cloud
nicht ums Wetter geht
okay, das ist eines der unkreativsten
Cloud Jokes, die ich seit langer Zeit
gesehen hab
aber die Stellanzeige
ist mir jetzt gar nicht mal schlecht
du weißt, dass es bei der Cloud nicht ums Wetter geht
und betreust Entwicklungskundensystem
im Rechenzentrum, okay, aber im Rechenzentrum
ist nicht in der Cloud
ist das nicht irgendwie so ein bisschen ein Widerspruch
oder, hä?
Private Cloud
also, ne Private Cloud ist für mich
nicht ein eigenes
Rechenzentrum, wo ich
irgendwelche Software betreibe
wo vielleicht irgendwo das Wort Cloud
drinnen auftaucht, ne Private Cloud ist
für mich immer noch bei Azure oder
Google, aber halt nicht Public im Internet
erreichbar, das ist doch ganz was anderes
du hast eigene Kundenprojekte
an denen du arbeitest von den Aufnahmen
du bist Microsoft
Super Admin, okay, da fall ich
schon mal prinzipiell raus
du kümmerst dich um Systembetreuung, Systemadministration
und Systemverwaltung
First Level
und Windows
muss das sein, ja?
also wie gesagt, ich find's echt
nicht schlecht gemacht, diese Arbeit, für mich
wär's überhaupt nix
du kennst dich aus und kümmerst dich um
nachhaltige Problembehebung, gegebenenfalls
Konfigurationsanwendung, okay, alles klar
jetzt nur eine Minute Bewerbung
oh, die haben's aber eilig
erst mal Triple Bildschirm
Arbeitsplatz und ein Notebook
so muss das sein, diese Sorte
von Telefon hab ich auch schon öfters gesehen
hier erst mal schön Dashboard
an der Wand, was sehen wir denn da oben
Leute, was ist denn das für eine Monitoring-Software
es sieht mir nicht aus wie
Zabbix und ist das
Ichinga oder sowas
oder, es ist
weder, es sieht nicht wirklich aus
wie Grafana, es sieht nicht aus wie CheckMk
nicht unbedingt
es sieht auch nicht aus wie
Zabbix oder Prometheus
keine Ahnung
zumindest ist da grad ziemlich viel rot
Leute, ist das
steht da 195
Probleme, da steht doch 195
oder, es ist zwar geblurrt
aber es sieht aus wie 195
wartet mal
ah, jetzt erkennt man's, jetzt erkennt man's
aber es ist auf jeden Fall dreistellig, oder
195 Probleme
deswegen brauchen die auch so dringend
einen neuen Admin, ja
AI-Upscaling
also Leute, ohne Scheiß
wenn ihr das deblurrt bekommt
weil es ist ja kompletter Informationsloss
und sowas drunter, da bin ich mal gespannt
aber es ist dreistellig, oder
ich glaub, da können wir uns schon drauf einigen
das sind deine Benefits
überdurchschnittlich Gehalt
ganz einfach, wir zahlen mehr als die
ok, das ist ne Ansage
es wär aber cool, wenn ein paar Zahlen
da stehen würden, aber das ist ne gute Ansage
übrigens, ich find die Aufmachung der Stellenanzeige
ziemlich gut
das ist genau der Stil, der mir gefällt
auch mit den Emojis und sowas
neueste technische Ausstellung
ja wenigstens einer, der mal ordentliche Benefits
hinschreibt, wir statten dich nicht aus
sondern auch Homeoffice
flexible Arbeitsplatzgestaltung
feste Arbeitsplätze brauchen wir nicht, du kannst
flexible Homeoffice-Regelung
eigene IQ-Kreditkarte
und Essenszulage
auch gut
abwechslungsreiche Team-Events
hey Leute, ganz im Ernst, ich persönlich hab
meistens keinen Bock auf großartige Team-Events
nach der Arbeit abends
aber es gibt Leute, die finden das cool
für mich ist das jetzt kein großes Benefit
aber solange das keine Pflichtveranstaltungen sind
ist doch ok, gibt Leute, die machen es gerne
sollen sie es machen
gleichzeitig auf Wunsch bezahlte Überstunden
wie, auf Wunsch bezahlte Überstunden?
achso, ich kann also auf Wunsch bezahlte Überstunden
oder Urlaub, achso, ich wollt grad sagen, wie
man wünscht sich da nichts, dass seine Überstunden bezahlt werden
aber die meinen Urlaub oder
oder Bezahlung, ok
IQ-Wohnzimmer
Billardart
Tischkicker und Spielekonsole
alles in unserem Lofi
Lofi, alter
Loftbüro
egal ob während oder
da halt ich persönlich wenig davon
weil das oftmals ein bisschen so ausartet
in die Richtung
wer es benutzt, gilt als jemand
der halt nicht arbeitet in der Zeit
aber kommt auf die Kultur der Firma an
kann man jetzt so nicht sagen
freie Firmenwagenwahl
klingt doch auch ganz ok
guck mal, die sind so richtig
agil und happy
wir möchten uns noch kurz vorstellen
das sind wir, modernes Loftbüro
flexible Arbeitsplätze, nicht zu vergessen
das IQ-Wohnzimmer
haben die auch alle bei mir
einen Prime-Sub?
sonst wüsste ich nicht, wie das mit IQ funktionieren soll
haben die ein Video? Wo?
ne, gibt kein Video
das sieht nur aus wie ein Video
das ist kein Video
das sieht nur so aus
unsere Vision, ganz einfach
wir führen ein gesundes Unternehmen um uns
und unseren Familien
eine solide Lebensgrundlage
also ehrlich
ich finde die Stellenanzeige nicht schlecht
es ist überhaupt nicht
das worauf ich Bock hätte
allein schon wenn ich First Level und Windows und sowas
in Kombination oder Microsoft
hätte ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf
aber ganz ehrlich, das finde ich
ist eine gute Stellenanzeige
das ist nicht
super krasses
wir feiern uns selbst ab und schreiben
0815 Random Business
Bullshit-Words hin
die Seite ist gut gemacht, auch so als möchte man
genau die richtigen Leute ansprechen
ich weiß nicht was sagt die, also ich finde die Stellenanzeige gut
auch diese Call to Action
wie man das ja im Marketing
Jargon nennt
finde ich auch sehr sinnvoll
weil vielleicht guckt sich das
jetzt jemand an und denkt sich so, alter
ich hab eh keinen Bock mehr auf meinen aktuellen Job
so lass mal bewerben
oh guck mal, sie haben sogar noch einen
so einen Assistent
sprichst du fließend Deutsch, ja
sowas ähnliches zumindest
ich spreche Twitch
Poggers Sprache
was ist dir bei deinem Job am wichtigsten?
etwas Bewegen, Sicherheit, ein tolles teamfreies Arbeiten
Geld
Geld ist Sicherheit
Sicherheit ist für mich
eher sowas wie, der Job ist morgen noch da
weil eigentlich ist mir
die Sicherheit meines Jobs
ich kann nicht Sicherheit
anklicken, wir haben letztens so ein Ranking
ausgefüllt und da war Sicherheit bei mir
glaube ich auf dem vorletzten Platz
freies Arbeiten
ja, ok, Homeoffice
wir interpretieren das mal
als Homeoffice Möglichkeiten, dann nehmen wir mal freies Arbeiten
Wie viel Erfahrung hast du
bereits auf deinem Gebiet in über 5 Jahren?
Hast du einen gültigen Führerschein?
Ja
Braucht man das? Was ist denn, wenn ich Nein sag?
Wie jetzt?
Hä?
Alter
Wie kaputt ist der Assistent?
Was passiert denn jetzt, wenn ich Ja und Nein ankreuze?
Jein
So, ich hab einen, aber ich darf grad nicht
fahren, weil ich
weil sie mir abgenommen haben, oder was?
Was möchtest du in den nächsten 2 Jahren
erreichen? Persönlich wachsen
Ich bin 1,74, da kann man
nicht mehr mehr dran machen
Führungsaufgaben übernehmen, Alter
Ok, vielleicht liegt es auch am Darkreader
dass die Seite so
dass die Seite so leckt
Ein Auge
Was möchtest du in den nächsten 2 Jahren erreichen?
Persönlich wachsen, fachlich weiterentwickeln
Ok, fachlich weiterentwickeln ist das einzige
was davon passt
Profil
Ja, hab ich
Ich hab ein LinkedIn-Profil
Hahahaha
Nein, ich poste das
da nicht rein, ich poste nicht mein
LinkedIn-Profil, ich habe, ich will mich ja da
gar nicht bewerben, ja
Ist einfach nur just for fun
Nein, nein, mach ich nicht
Aber man kriegt jetzt gar kein Ergebnis, oder so
Ey, das ist ja doof
Ich dachte, da kommt jetzt irgendwas bei raus
Ok, aber Leute, ich würde es
nicht machen wollen, den Job
Aber die Sterneanzeige
finde ich gut
Muss ja auch mal so eine Kombination geben
Du musst dir in meinem Profil noch schreiben, dass ich Artstilung
Ich hab gar keinen Zugang
mehr zu dem Profil
Ich hab das irgendwann mal mit einer random
internetgenerierten Handynummer auf einer random
One-Way-Email-Adresse freigeschaltet
Keine Chance, da komm ich nie wieder dran
Ja, ich guck mir nur Sachen an
Nordic, danke für den Sub
Ey, Till, danke für den Sub
Ich bin total weit hinten dran
Ne Stunde, Leute, ich bin ne Stunde
hinten dran im Chat
Aufs
Falsche
Nein, hab ich nicht
Cityboy
Du bist ewig schon am Start, oder?
Bist du noch da?
Du bist ewig schon am Start, gell?
Ich kann mich noch dran erinnern, dass
der Fabian und ich
oder so
ein Video gemacht haben mit User-Fragen
Und ich glaube,
da warst du schon dabei
Der Name sagt mir noch irgendwas
Okay, wahrscheinlich ist er schon wieder weg
Das ist ne Stunde her
Aber falls du noch da bist, Cityboy, sag mal, ob du das warst
Das klingt ein bisschen nach
meiner alten Firma
Oh, wird der jetzt highlighted oder sowas?
Okay
Du willst lachen und so? Okay, das hatten wir schon
Ed
Lorz
Ja, die Sachen hab ich gemeint
Hatten wir schon
Vogue-Web-Request
Alter, Powershell-Enjoyers
am Start
Chat, haben wir Powershell-Enjoyers
hier? Auch wenn's
ein bisschen unverständlich ist
Wer von euch ist
offen bekennender Powershell-Enjoyer?
Tatsächlich, es gibt
sie wirklich, ja
Haben die auch dein Ohr flambiert?
Nein
Mein Ohr wurde nicht flambiert
Aber die Haare wurden
am Ohr ordentlich entfernt
Es könnte auch sein, dass
du mal C++ im
Das könnte nicht sein, das war sogar schon
Wir machen jetzt Chat
im Schnelldurchlauf
Das hab ich auch gefragt
Gut für mich, es haben wenige Leute mich direkt
erwähnt im Chat, da hab ich jetzt ne gute Ausrede
warum ich das so schnell skippen kann
Der Name sagt mir irgendwas
Aber ich kann mich jetzt nicht mehr direkt
dran erinnern
Leute, wir nähern uns
der aktuellen Uhrzeit
Was hältst du von dieser Uhr?
Du hast irgendwelche
Session-IDs reingepostet, die mach ich mal
raus. Ach ne, das ist nicht
die Session-ID, das ist die ID vom Job
Indeed
Java-Entwickler
MWD
The best
of ICT
with a human touch
Okay
Was ist ICT?
Information
Technology
Computer
Okay, wir müssen uns
jetzt schnell machen, wir haben ja höchstens noch ne viertel Stunde Zeit
Dann Bedgetime
Communication
Ah, ja, okay
Wir suchen aktuell nach einer
engagierten Person, die als Teil unseres
Projektteams individuell
Bla bla bla
Deine Aufgaben umfassen
Die Entwicklung, Tests, Installation
und Support von offenen Systemen
Das ist auch wieder so global galaktisch, oder?
Entwicklung, Tests,
Installation und Support von
offenen Systemen
Du solltest dich jetzt
Ja, ich meine, ich verstehe, warum die das schreiben
Wahrscheinlich ist der Schwerpunkt auch hier drauf, aber
Trotzdem immer so blöd
das zu schreiben, finde ich
Wenn du über einen IT nahen
Studium, bla bla bla
Okay
Das erwarte dich, entwickle individuelle
Kundenlösungen als fester Bestandteil
Du bist ein Projektfeind und bekannst deine technischen
Kenntnisse für den
Okay, das ist auch äußerst
Ja, okay
Du wirkst an der
Erstellung von Anforderungsleistungen
Du stimmst komplexe Funktionale weit zu weit
Schnittstellen fachlich ab
Entwicklung, Testen
Der Kundenumgebung
Kundenkontakt, das ist schon mal
Ziemlicher MonkaS-Faktor
So wie der Support für die laufenden
Systeme, Support auch ziemlicher MonkaS-Faktor
Wir sollten mal
eine MonkaS-Faktortabelle
aufstellen und anhand dessen können wir dann
Einheitlich Stellenanzeigen bewerten
Also Kundensupport, End-User-Support ist
extremer MonkaS-Faktor
Das bringst du mit
Berufserfahrung
ist ein Plus, aber kein Muss
Okay, also das ist
quasi so eine Art Junior-bis
nicht mehr Junior-Stelle
Du hast
Erfahrung in einigen der folgenden Bereichen
Application-Server, Oracle
Weblogic, noch nie gehört
Websphere
Alter
Moment, Moment, da reicht das
Normale gar nicht mehr für
Da brauchen wir schon den hier
Websphere
Alter
Wer benutzt denn den Schrott noch
Das ist was, was man 1998
benutzt hat
Echt, SAP benutzt noch Websphere
Ach
Bei SAP wundert mich eh nichts
Anwendungsentwicklung in Java und
Java Enterprise
Die Programmiersprache ist in beiden
Fällen die gleiche
Datenbanken, Oracle
Microsoft
Db2
HTML5 und Javascript
Entwickel
und Orchestrierung von Schnittstellen
SOAP REST
Okay, ja
Oldschool XML Shit
Okay, damit kann ich was anfangen
Aber was ist
USLC, das ist doch bestimmt irgendein
Oracle-Schrott, oder?
Nein, Open Service for Lifecycle
Collaboration
Hab ich legit
noch nie gehört
XSL, das klingt
wie ein Excel-Fileformat
Ja, ist doch sowas im Prinzip
So
Verantwortung, Einsatz und Kreativität
Du hast Freude am Umgang mit Menschen, löst gerne Probleme
Moment
Das sind zwei grundlegend unterschiedliche
Paar Schuhe
Du löst gerne Probleme
und du hast Freude am Umgang
mit Menschen, das ist nichts, was
auch nur annähernd was miteinander zu tun hätte
Also
ich würde sogar fast behaupten,
dass die meisten Leute,
die mega gut sind,
im technischen Probleme lösen,
eher wenig Freude im Umgang mit
Menschen haben, und Leute,
die sehr viel Freude im Umgang mit anderen Menschen
haben, im Durchschnitt nicht so richtig gut
im Lösen technischer Probleme sind
Zumal Menschen auch gerne Probleme verursachen
Reisebereitschaft
Okay, da wäre es schon mal wieder vorbei
bei mir
Möglichkeit von Homeoffice
Ehrlich gesagt,
die Stellenanzeige finde ich nur so mittel
Ähm
Wenn es das einzige ist, bei einem in der Nähe, kann man es ja mal
ausprobieren, aber ziemlich 0815
langweilig und bla bla
Also, da hat mich die letzte deutlich
mehr überzeugt
Auch wenn ich mich bei der nicht bewerben würde, weil ich
keinen Bock auf Windows Support habe, aber
Insgesamt war die letzte doch
viel angenehmer
Du bekommst einen Strompreis-Rabatt,
wenn du bei Energie Baden-Württemberg
anfängst. Das ist in der heutigen
Zeit wahrscheinlich auf lange Sicht
mehr wert als ein bisschen mehr Kohle im Vertrag
Wenn das so weitergeht
An's Trinken erinnern? Oh ja, unbedingt, Leute
Gut, dass ihr Bescheid gesagt habt
Ja, Offenbach kann das schon mal
passieren
Das haben die in der Matrix aber nicht gesagt
Also mir fällt
in der Matrix keine Stelle ein,
wo die auch nur ansatzweise
was von Cloud überhaupt gesagt haben
Man darf nicht vergessen, Matrix ist
von 1998 oder so
Da hat an Cloud noch keiner gedacht
3?
Du hast subscribed, aber du hast mich nur ans
Trinken erinnert, aber ich hab grad was gedrungen
Ich halte
von den meisten
Genau so musst du agil sein, Methoden
nix. Es muss zum jeweiligen Unternehmen
zum jeweiligen Projekt und zur jeweiligen
Arbeitsweise passen
Ein bisschen Übersicht bei den ganzen Sachen haben
ist nicht verkehrt, aber ganz ehrlich
ich könnte dir jetzt nicht aus dem Stehgreif sagen
was genau sie jetzt safe
unterscheidet von den ganzen anderen Dingern
N3oG, Dankeschön für den Sub
Dann Sub exzellent
Iq increase
für den Chat
Also, weißt du woher
meine Definition von Private Cloud
mitkommt? Von Google
Und Google nennt
wenn man sich
bei ihnen in der Cloud
ein Projekt macht ohne Public Internet Access
nennt das Private Cloud
Sicherlich ist das
ein Begriff wie vieles andere
Jeder versteht ein bisschen was anderes drunter
Aber
wenn es was ist, was du selbst betreibst
in einem Rechenzentrum
dann finde ich
geht das nicht als Cloud durch
Genauso wie Next Cloud
eigentlich gar nichts
Null mit Cloud zu tun hat
Es ist weder verteilt, distributed
noch irgendwie
über mehrere Standorte oder sonst was
Guck mal, wir haben es fast geschafft
Okay, da müssen wir uns jetzt
aber wirklich beeilen
Also, die suchen einen
DevOps, wenigstens die Seite nicht komplett
weiß, da kriegt man nicht gleich
Augenkrebs, oder wird nicht blind
von, DevOps Engineer
MWD in der Informatik
Ken hat einen grünen Daumen
Ken blüht
in IT-Systemen auf
Sind sie wie Ken?
Boah, das schmerzt ja schon, das zu lesen
Wer hat sich das denn ausgedacht?
Can you stop?
Unsere
Mitarbeiter motivieren
Menschen, die zu uns passen
Denn wir geben ihnen...
Bla bla bla bla bla
Was sie erwartet
Also, im IT-Bereich sind knapp
Blablabla
Spielen sich Zahlen
Vielfalt der Spezialisten
Arbeiten überwiegend in agilen
Agile
Projekts
Auch in modernen
Internet-basierten Architekturen
auf Java-Enterprise Basis
Internet-basiert
Sie wollten nicht Cloud schreiben, oder wie?
Naja
Langfristige Mitarbeit
In allen Phasen der anstehenden
Softwareproduktion werden
Okay
Alles klar
Mit ihrer Expertise verantworten
Sie die Continuous Delivery Pipelines
Klingt
passend dafür, was sie suchen
Sie sind für
die Einführung und Weiterentwicklung der Automatisierung
von Continuous Delivery Pipelines
verantwortlich
Durch ihr Know-how entwickeln wir uns weiter
Von ihnen werden
Details für die Bereiche Automatisierung
Test und Deployment von Java-Anwendungen
Primär
JBoss
Jakarta
Java
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Java
Sie arbeiten vertrauensvoll
Sie behalten den Überblick
Ja
Klingt alles ganz solide bis jetzt
Was sie auszeichnet
Man hat eine Ausbildung
Sie haben Erfahrung im Staging
und Betrieb von Java-Anwendungen
Was genau verstehen die
in diesem Zusammenhang mit Staging
Sowas wie
Quasi ein
Wie soll man sagen
Software
Update-Zyklus
Man testet erst was in einer Testumgebung
Dann in irgendeiner
Entwicklungsumgebung, dann in einer Testingumgebung
Live-Umgebung
Wahrscheinlich
Idealerweise verfügen sie über
Erfahrung mit Containern, Docker, Potman
und deren Orchestrierung
Jawohl
Sie verfügen über gute Kenntnisse im Bereich Linux
Ihre Deutschkenntnisse sind mindestens auf
B2 Niveau
Weiß ich nicht
Persönlichkeit
Sie sind kreativ und denken
Sicher Arbeitsplatte
Flexible
Mobiles Arbeit
3 Tage pro Woche
Wäre mir persönlich zu wenig
Hätte ich keinen Bock drauf
3 Tage Anwesenheit
2 Tage Homeoffice
Klingt ganz
Brauchbar, wenn auch
Irgendwie ein bisschen 0815
Und für mich wäre es ein K.O.
Kriterium, dass ich quasi
3 Tage die Woche ins Büro fahren müsste
Klingt jetzt nicht so super
Wo ich sagen würde, oh ja das ist genau das
Was mich anspricht, aber hey
Gut, dass sie wenigstens schreiben
Was sie machen und nicht so super
Generic Sprüche drin haben
Wie wir entwickeln
Business Enterprise High Performance
Schnittstellen oder sowas
Sondern dass da echt drin steht, was Sache ist
Hier unten auch ein bisschen drin steht
Was Sache ist, ja
Also ich würde sagen überdurchschnittliche
Stellenanzeige, aber
Nichts wo ich jetzt sagen würde
Oh jetzt eh nicht, wie gesagt ich suche ja keinen Job aktuell
Wo ich
mich beworben hätte
Aber
Wahrscheinlich nicht übel, ja
Schwer zu sagen, also
Wir haben heute eine Stellenanzeige
gesehen, die fand ich definitiv besser
Aber die anderen waren eigentlich fast alle schlechter
Ich sag fast, weil
ich mich nicht mehr an alle erinnern kann
Kannst du eine überbetriebliche Ausbildung
zum Physi empfehlen, 2 Jahre inklusive
Ähm
Was ist denn
eine überbetriebliche Ausbildung
Meinst du eine Umschulung vom Arbeitsamt
Oder was ist eine überbetriebliche Ausbildung
Umschulung vom Arbeitsamt
Im Ende ist wichtig, dass du deinen Abschluss hast
Wie du die gemacht hast
Ist wurscht, du bist Physi
Und hast einen IHK Zettel, wo drauf steht, du hast Physi gelernt
Und gut ist
Ähm
Schwierig könnte eventuell sein, das Praktikum zu finden
Wo du dein Projekt machen kannst
Würdest du eigentlich sagen, dass die Ausbildungszeit
Als Berufserfahrung zählt
Ok, da müssen wir jetzt unterscheiden Leute
Dankeschön für den Sub
Da müssen wir unterscheiden
Wenn du mich persönlich fragst
Ja, finde ich schon
Sehr viele wichtige Sachen lernt man in der Ausbildung
Wenn es um
Ja, Gehaltsfragen
Und Vertragsfragen geht dann nicht
Also aus meiner Sicht schon, aber offiziell nicht
Euer Silverlight
Da hätte ich ja Bock drauf
Eine Silverlight Anwendung zu bauen
Warum arbeiten so viele Unternehmen
Mit so veralterter Software
Oder auch Pequemlichkeit oder fehlendes Interesse
Oh, das ist sehr umfangreich
Und natürlich von Unternehmen zu Unternehmen
Verschieden
Aber du kannst dir vorstellen, dass Unternehmen
Prinzipiell sehr
Wenig Risiko eingehen wollen
Und wenn die was haben
Was sie vor 15 Jahren entwickelt haben
Und was funktioniert, sehen die meisten keinen Grund
Das grundlegend zu überarbeiten
Weil es funktioniert ja
Das ist glaube ich so eines der Hauptgründe
Dafür
Je neuer das Unternehmen ist
Umso neuere Software verwenden die auch
Und umso neuer das Projekt ist
Und umso neuer die Software in dem Projekt benutzt wird
Aber wenn das Unternehmen
Ältere Software hat, selbst entwickeln
Und es das schon eine Weile gibt
Kurz oder lang hast du halt einfach ollen Kram
Manche sind auch übertrieben
Auf Sicherheit
Fokussiert schon so sehr, dass es schon wieder unsicher wird
Es ist
Es ist so pauschal schwer zu sagen
So, fertig
Chat, ich geh ins Bett
Nicer Schwätz streamen
Und
Wir sehen uns, bis dann, machts gut
See you